hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday and
i up just for a monday
morning podcast i almost got myself
confused there maybe because i'm excited
about my guest i'm just checking in on
you
i have an amazingly backlit guest this
week where am i trying to find this one
check me out
yeah yeah there's all kinds of stuff
from uh echo brain
and some other band you might have heard
of metallica
the one and only jason neustadt what's
going on man
bill burr it's good to see your face
thanks for having me bud yeah it's good
to see i haven't seen you since i think
san francis no was it san francisco yeah
i think our boys came down from the chop
house and we hung out with you and went
out to dinner and stuff at a time
that's right that's okay i wasn't sure
if it was that one weird time i ran into
you in paris
oh that on your birthday on your i
turned your 50th birthday and you bought
me some drinks you were very nice yeah
and you weren't really drinking then but
you still got convinced to do it and you
and uh nia came over and met us at that
that club real late yeah drinks and
stuff it was fun that was right before
i quit drinking that was june i quit
drinking in november yeah i haven't
drank since and i'm not gonna lie to you
i miss it yeah being sober sucks
it's good
it's
good for the kids but dude yeah i'm sure
making taking life in the face every day
yeah and not being able to just be like
you know what i'm gonna alter my
experience it's like nope i just have to
sit here
sit here and take it but that's not why
we're talking today we're talking today
because i can't believe this this is
making me old as hell
it is we're coming up on or i think it
might have just happened the 30th
anniversary
of the release
of the metallica self-titled is it black
album people called black i'm but it's
just called metallica right right yeah
just
right yep
30 years man you know i was looking at
then that's on all the all-time lists
that's like one of those back and black
michael jackson thriller eagles greatest
hits it just never
goes off the charts and uh
truly well when you were making it did
you
can you guys are making i know these are
old questions but when you were making
that thing
going from injustice for all
you know and then to that
you know were you sitting there going
like are we making a big mistake here is
this like
you know because there was hundreds of
shows in between that time right between
we released justice and we got around to
making the black album hundreds of shows
all around the world 40 or something
countries and doing our thing and really
building the following that was the big
time to build the following because
justice hit so successfully and one by
one and back be that was before inner
tube or any of that stuff so we had one
person at a time take the music to the
people in the flesh the way it should be
no screens in between us and them just
the direct connection the real i know i
hate that they even do that at sporting
events like take got rid of the class
clown in your section because
everybody's staring
at the uh at the screen so
i feel fortunate i feel really fortunate
to have been a part of that thing as we
were spearheading you know going to a
lot of places that maiden and ac dc had
already been but they really paved the
path or at least cut the jungle down for
us to get to the next place you know
what i'm saying we really did that after
them we got to give credit as things go
chronologically but they really
what was your big like uh
place that either you you
always wanted to play or all of a sudden
one night you were there and you never
even dreamed to play in there because it
was it was so big did you have any of
those
i think early on man the rose bowl when
we did monsters of rock in 1988 right
with van halen headlines
it's okay bill goes van halen scorpions
dawkin metallica kingdom come from from
the top down
so we're on we come on after kingdom
come at 3 o'clock in the afternoon it's
112 in the [ __ ] shade you know and
there's already 60 000 people inside the
bowl and the thing as soon as we came on
it flushed like a turlet man everybody
came down from the seats onto the floor
and then lit took all the seats off the
floor and threw them up at the
they passed them over their heads in
bunches we had to stop in the middle of
whiplash
and throw all the chairs to get down
there was a giant pile behind the stage
like a pyre you know getting ready to
burn this big pile of all those metal
chairs but they would come up in
sections of four and you'd see him fly
over people's heads and people get
knocked and try to catch him and that
and then it's overwhelming all the
guards in between
the stage and the in the you know the
guard there man so finally uh we're
standing standing back and watching the
crowd do this
they get done they give us the green
light again we go right back out and
whatever it was third verse of whiplash
one two three right where we left off
and and
and so they had by that time cleared the
space for them to do what they wanted to
do so there was sixty thousand whatever
it would have been on the floor maybe
fifty thousand on the floor
on the field as it were and pits were
six or eight hundred people at a time
five or six pits across the whole field
just just madness it was being invented
and pioneered you know
and what what what kind of uh was it
scary was it amazing like what are you
thinking when you're standing there
you're worried like oh no our fans are
destroying this is this going to affect
future shows are you just sort of
standing there like a bystander like how
do you keep playing the song while
you're watching that staying focused
like is that chair coming at me right
there's the thing so you know how the
turn your head has to be on a swivel you
know and there's with with police
officers or football players hockey
players wrestlers i mean anybody i mean
anybody in life right you get it right
driving head got to be on a swivel well
it's like that to the oomph you know
like you got because you the main thing
about playing successfully in an
ensemble is knowing what's coming next
right you know you got to know that then
that's the verse and where you are and
boom boom boom you do 30 songs over two
and a half hours and they all got to be
just like that and not miss a [ __ ]
note you know you got to know what's
coming so that's all going on as your
demand or whatever your role and then
you got all this other [ __ ] happening
hey there's some boobs hey there's some
blood hey there's some
bones points sticking out
like that so you really got to keep your
mind in the game dude yeah while you're
playing an audio time so much of that
album was at least it could have been in
four or four sure
yeah man and you gotta yeah you gotta
really be paying attention there and
there's only a few times really that we
ever stop stop the show and usually that
was when one of us was harmed
that's unreal well i got to tell you
something about your that the the
metallica album
is
there's certain albums that ever since
the 80s and the 90s when i was going to
the gym
or if i was sitting down playing at a
kit or whatever you could just hit play
from the beginning
and go all the way to the end and it
would get you through your workout it'd
get you through your drive you didn't
have to you know make a playlist
and it was literally like ac dc back in
black
you know appetite
and your album
it was just one of those things that was
the perfect level of uh
i don't know what i don't know like i
that's what f fascinates me
you know when you said you wanted to do
this and i started looking
at the albums that were on that list and
you start thinking like what is it about
those things and uh
i know that musicians probably sit there
and they look at those lists and think
we need to obviously you know who
doesn't want to write an album like that
is there
is there a way to go for that or does it
just magically happen you're like oh
[ __ ] it's still selling 10 years later
it's still on the charts and like
like
many elements you know first of all
we're going to give credit to lars uh
for being
so into i mean
absorbed um engulfed
in the whole thing and the sequencing of
the record
and the sequencing of all the metallic
albums as they've come out and the
secret sequencing has become more
developed and better and better like the
second song has to be that and the
seventh song has to be that and so and
so and that's why it's
appealing like you're talking about and
listenable in that way because of his
meticulous
you know attention paid to that um and
still to this day he is that guy and so
that credit should be there first
um and going back to what was like did
we know was happening when it was
happening um we had a lot of momentum
built up and like we were mentioning
before those hundreds of shows and stuff
and building the fan base uh and uh
justice being so successful and kind of
building building building on that
we knew there was a lot at stake and
sort of the powers that be and
management and so forth and everybody
threw a whole bunch of money into it so
we know that when that much money is
invested that there's something a big
chance of something really happening
because people are going to put all the
puzzle pieces in place and set us up for
success if we're able to knock that [ __ ]
down show by show and make people want
to come back and wanting more then we do
our part we knew that everybody else and
their roles and all those roles that
there are you're very familiar with in
your business so many different people
from the guy that sells the record to
the guy that helps us make the record
the crew guys everybody in between all
those people doing their job to the
right best of their ability to make it
successful so all those elements got to
kind of line up for that part of the
that's that side of it to come up with
the product and be ready to present the
product then you have to have the thing
about the demographic and like you're
speaking of the albums that came like
black back back in black was 1980 right
so you you were talking about records
that came in 1991 uh there was appetite
and uh and um a sound garden record in
nirvana and metallica appetite was 87.
okay so 87 and then and the big year
that came up was didn't
guns and roses do their other double
record and nirvana soundgarden yeah
released in three months james had their
dad that ritual
in 1990 but for me that's the all the
ones that that's
as far as that new
sort of because i didn't consider them
like grunge or whatever like just that
album is another one that i feel just
like you just put it on you hit play
and then like you know what any time i
have like music is play such a huge part
of my life any time especially you know
i got a drive i got to get through or a
flight i want to get through and i don't
want to have to keep looking down so
there's albums that you just uh
keep going back to but um almost con
almost part of your conditioning in a
way you know what i mean you know you
can rely on something in that way and
you go back to it because a lot of
things you can't so let that kind of
mentality i think that yeah you go back
to where you were what car you would you
sure oh dude man you always
like the the what i call the memory
money you know i don't want to say like
there's certain bands of style now
they're nostalgia acts they're called
yeah but there's certain bands if you're
around long enough 30 years is the mark
that i would usually call maybe it could
be 25. you're able to play for
generation after generation there's a
few generations coming to see your your
band you know so that's always a big
secret uh not a secret necessarily but
some part of the success that's a really
important uh key that people come and
keep coming back to it but someone want
to touch down really important like you
were saying there in in your business if
you're with your efforts for family
stuff with the other things you've done
through time with your your uh comedy
slugging it out five nights a week doing
your shows like we do our shows
um anyone in show business or an author
or something like that
you've got to find your audience that's
it that's the one number one thing then
everything else can happen after that
but you're going to ask how do you do
because
how i ended up finding my audience
was not caring about getting an audience
and just more just like doing what i
wanted to do yeah and just being more
like all right this is what
i i do you either like it or you don't
and i'm just gonna keep doing this until
enough people like it that i can fill up
whatever the heck i'm going in um the
hard part of my career
was early on when i was like what do
they want what are they looking for and
i was almost like in the crowd looking
at me you know this is the shirt you
want to wear this is this is what uh the
industry's buying right now and i always
tell like younger comics about that
going like you know it's sort of the
short game and it's also the greatest
way to get outside of what you have to
say because you're not you anymore
you're almost doing like like an acting
job and i always want to put like guys
like you
the band that you were in like you know
that stuff was you know really
i mean it was it was you know
as much as they were talking about metal
it was really hair metal which was
really just pop music yeah um so much of
that and what you guys did i mean i'd be
honest like what you guys did was too
hard for me until
the metallica my brothers were into that
[ __ ] going come on man you got to learn
how to play double bass and i'm like i
like the bottom [ __ ] and they were mad
at him get a double pedal and i wouldn't
do it and i missed out on all of you
guys
i didn't see all you guys until the
2000s but then that was the album then i
worked my way back
um
you know through metallica's like uh
catalog but i i always wondered like
you know
or i gotta say i'm envious of when you
sit there and you say you know you gotta
go out and get the crowd like as a comic
it's it's a fun feeling to turn a crowd
around and get them into you but i i i
was always wondering
you know what that was like as a band
that as a group be like a platoon like
we're gonna take this hill
and you get that that enjoyment like
uh afterwards like you know if i want to
crowd over i could come off stage it's
it's like a
it's just me
i don't get to go over to somebody else
like you know i don't have that moment
in the show where somebody else in the
band looks at me like [ __ ] this
we're getting these like i remember he
was hearing a story one time of uh
i think simon wright when he was playing
for aac dc at nights when you know they
were kind of tired he said he would look
up and angus would just be looking at
him like come on man let's do this and i
was thinking i got like i got literally
like a rush of adrenaline
you imagine trying to keep up with the
angus dude [ __ ]
man i know oh jeez you know he used to
have like it looked like a sh like he
was standing in a shower like he would
be playing it would just be pouring off
no doubt
he's worn off his uh his um
his forearm so
what exactly like what is the packaging
is there a special packaging here for
the 30th anniversary as far as like
um
what we're promoting here today
oh well yeah they they did the black box
thing and it had all kinds of i mean
there's so much archives you know we
recorded everything in proper cameras
and proper through all of time and
photograph everything there's so much to
dig from and once again back to lars
he's so good at their archiving
archiving of things
that helps out a lot when they're
digging for that so there's a lot of
cool things there um i did want to touch
on what you're talking about there
though i think it's important uh the
difference between being in an ensemble
or being on your own you know it's like
uh the best uh athletes so jordan
who gets the ball when there's three
seconds left the dude that can [ __ ]
shoot and has the highest percentage so
you know if he misses it's like he's
saying it said
if he if he hits it he's the king of the
world and so when you know when you're
by when you're by yourself and doing
your own thing if the show don't go so
great then you're the one that has to
take that brunt and if it goes great you
take the glory and the shine and then it
pats down the back when it's the team
you know the team takes the hit and the
team takes the glory so it's different
you share you share in the anguish and
or the pride
what's the biggest uh
triumph
you've had as a musician as far as like
like the you you're uh i mean
i don't act like you know
you know every year you have like that
show where you're like oh man that was
the that was the one but what what are
what are some of the ones that stand out
during the different phases you know
echo brain metallica all of that stuff
like what uh
what are some of the ones that if you're
sitting on your back porch you just
think of like man i was i was [ __ ]
good that night
or that once again you're the the
individual one or the team one you know
and i think i probably remember team
ones more than i remember individual
performances so the ones that have been
glorified over time and sensationalized
like the big russian shows and that
stuff not unforgettable of course quite
well documented but there's other ones
that are personally huge for us as a
unit um day on the green in oakland
october 12
okay that was bill graham's last proper
show that he put on period
um that's a big goddamn deal in the bay
area man you know he took it he took a
chance on metallica back in 82 3-4 or
whatever that was you know and then they
came back home to headline that thing
after we've been on the road for the
black album a couple months we just
started firing on all cylinders mtv came
there with 19 freaking cameras and did
their thing and recorded it nice and it
sounded so killer on the tv and i
remember playing a big alembic six
string bass with it you know the string
on the top the biggest brown is your
[ __ ] finger like big telephone cable
on that [ __ ] right but tuned down for
sabbat true so it goes
[Music]
and just taking people's freaking
feelings out man you can see you can see
their sternums you know like come flying
up onto the stage they're standing next
to the base bins in the front right just
getting destroyed
but we we were we were hitting right
then with such precision
and the uh
momentum and like the what do you call
it we're um levitating
as in a way you know there was
so much success and every day there was
another report on how how much radio was
playing nothing else matters or some of
these things that we had never ever
experienced as far as exposure for our
kind of music you know so there's what
was that like how how excited did the
um
the james and all echo with with all of
those guys were they excite like it just
seems like some a lot of times when i
just watch stuff about that band it just
seems like it's work work work work work
work work i was wondering if they ever
picked their head up and were like hey
man
look what we did here this is
this is amazing
a not uh not a lot of time
to look up and say look what you did or
the accomplishment it took a while until
after everything's settled and you can
look back at it but as it's happening
the days were very long and very
demanding and so you know that you just
can't imagine like yeah man you learn
how to play bass you spend all that time
learning how to play drums you took that
time now you can go up and you remember
stuff together and rock some [ __ ] okay
now all of a sudden that where it used
to fill up 97 of the demand now that's
about that much over here you know you
still got to keep your chops together
right but the other 45 percent is filled
up with videos and
interviews and the things and the things
and the things and all the things that
you never you knew about some some of it
but so there's no way to predict at all
because once again it was kind of being
invented in a certain way for this style
and stuff so we were taking the
once again how did you keep your your
you know
your wits about you because i can get
pretty grumpy
when when it it gets to the point of
like guys like i the number one thing
i'm here for is to do a [ __ ] show
right these people paid all of this
money
and i need to i need to destroy tonight
and if i'm going to be you know going
here and then going there and then do a
quick thing here and uh you know
nowadays the big thing is you know can
you make a video
can you make a video say it you know now
that you tweeted it you instagramed it
you did all of that [ __ ] can you then
make an a video on top of that just to
like uh
it's like you're signing everything in
triplicate except it's like like
um
like those are the days where you know i
i you know
i don't know i i really just go like
what the [ __ ] man
it's almost better when no one knew who
i was i could just sit in the
condo and stare at the wall and think
about jokes
that's true i i feel that very much in
that time i think we all probably did um
it was there was so much going on though
and such a schedule and so many shows
coming in at being added on each time
some new country put us on their radio
that never would play heavy music before
so all of a sudden their
government or whatever invites us to
play see if it's an islamic nation or
something like that and they wouldn't
let white westernize music in there the
white devil's in and all of a sudden
they know that they can make a whole
bunch of money obviously they invite us
anyway type of stuff things start
happening like that you know and nobody
wants to be the link you know nobody
wants to be the weak one on the stage
everybody has their own way to keep
yourself up you're asking like how to
keep your [ __ ] together because it's
it's not just one person trying to keep
your thing together remember your jokes
remember your program and stuff it's
elbow to elbow plane train automobile um
a lot of a lot of uh substances and a
lot of crazy [ __ ] going on and all the
other things that that make the stories
you know but a lot of the behind the
scenes that don't make the stories
uh also where you really got to be
patient with each other because you know
what's at stake it's an awful lot there
to because it's really quick you can't
blow up the band yeah and you want and
you want everything to keep going as it
is because that's what i'm working so
hard for is the success attention the
reason we do what we do bill is to show
off right come on now right
for me
yeah well both though there's elements
of both now come on man come on oh no
there definitely is
all right everybody it's liquid iv or is
my dumbass just called it liquid four
liquid iv
uh cooler weather
makes it easier to miss signs of
dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body properly
hydrated flu season is in full swing
proper hydration and vitamins can help
support a strong immune system making
hydration a priority helps us feel
healthier on a day-to-day basis and
fuels us to be our our highest potential
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone not only
that but the product tastes great with
flavors like watermelon strawberry and
lemon lime are you going to be enjoying
a few extra drinks now that the holidays
are approaching this is what you need
having liquid iv in the house has been
great i'm never worried about being able
to get myself back to 100 if i'm feeling
a little sluggish liquid iv hydrates
faster and more efficiently than water
alone contains five essential vitamins
more vitamin c than an orange and has as
much potassium as a banana healthier
than a sugary sports drink yeah those
things are the worst no artificial
flavors or preservatives and less sugar
than apple an apple pie made with
ingredients
less sugar than an apple than an apple
sorry not an apple pie i was like what
the [ __ ] kind of claim is that less
sugar than an apple sorry made with
clean ingredients no gmo vegan and free
of gluten dairy and soy grab your
favorite liquid iv flavors nationwide at
walmart or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquid iv.com
and use the code burr b-u-r-r at
checkout this is a great way to stay
healthy and not put on extra pounds
that's 25 off anything you order when
you get better hydration today using
promo code burr at liquid iv.com
okay oh look at me one of my favorites
here thompson cigars
i
love a cigar
um it's a great way to just kick back
relax reflect on your life great
conversation
and they're absolutely delicious that's
why you gotta check out thompson cigar
whether you're working from home or just
kicking back after a week of being
essential there's no better way to relax
than with a premium cigar they've got
the best prices on the biggest brands in
the business from mca noodle
to monte cristo
looking to try a new rare top rated
blends but you don't want to splurge on
a box
check out thompson's cigar tour
smattering of five different blends
delivered to your doorstep each month in
thompson's five pack fever program they
have the largest selection of samplers
online with the option to build your own
or choose from over 300 different five
pack options to mix and match they also
send out insane cigar deals with
personalized email preference options so
you can sign up to receive them all or
just the days you feel like reading
emails
thompson's cigar company continues to be
the number one choice for premium cigars
in the usa because they delivered the
very best
customer service um
oh i had one of their cigar samplers
that they sent me uh one of my fathers
i'm now into
and then they also send me uh
you know the ones that i love um
i like the uh jesus christ what are the
auroras uh so sit back and take a break
from all the craziness with the cigar
from thompson cigar company these guys
rarely do offers but right now thompson
is offering our listeners 15 off orders
over 75
or 25 our orders
uh of over 99
great for the holiday season if your old
man smokes or your buddies do to take
advantage of these incredible savings
simply go to thompsoncigard.com and use
the promo code b-u-r-r when you are
ready to check out that website is
thompson t-h-o-m-p-s-o-n-cigar.com
and use the promo code burr that's it
everybody i have a wonderful holiday
season
as we move into thanksgiving hey here's
something um
you know remember when you were back in
school when you were a kid and you had
your first base and you remember like
not paying attention in class because
all you were doing was thinking about
going home and playing your base you
know for me that was like drums or going
out and playing sports or some [ __ ]
and um
there were a couple of times
you know where out here i was gonna sit
in with the band
and then there was like rehearsal and
everything and all of a sudden like my
drums
became like work
like ah [ __ ] i gotta go down there and
we gotta do this three times and it
starts to become that i was wondering
during that touring
like it was there any sort of ritual you
did with you and your base to keep
the excitement it's like it's almost
like when a comedian when you're sick of
all your jokes
and you go up there like going like oh
my god if i have to hear my [ __ ]
voice saying this stupid idea how are
these people still laughing at this
like to play you know like you guys were
playing you know
300 friggin shows a year
like how did you keep the excitement of
like still feeling like you know it was
like magic having an instrument was
magic when you were a kid and first
plugging in and hearing that how do you
stay connected with that and it doesn't
become like time to make the donuts
thinking about like what if i just moved
into a winnebago and just kept all this
tour money and i never
i just smoked weed and i played bass in
the back of my [ __ ] winnebago
wow that's a good thought um
there are definitely times that uh
how many
takes you did of inner sandman during a
week because of the american music
awards and the top of the pops and the
thing the thing and then the regular
shows too
um you know trying to stay on top of it
you still feel good and strong about
executing and presenting to the people
so it has a lot to do with the
adrenaline flow where everything can get
pretty numb your leg could be broken and
you're still going to go and play
because the jam is on once the entertain
once the intro tape comes on
and that [ __ ] that adrenaline dude
everything is lit up i i could i could
you know what what two marathons would
you like me to run right now
very much i think so it kind of becomes
a huge pain reliever and a numbing
device and then there's always the
favorite songs there's still a few
that come along every third song or
whatever that are such a challenge to
play no matter how many thousands of
times you played them right they're just
like you've got to be on your toes and
it's a thing where [ __ ] man i can do
this like an athlete very much like an
athlete so you're you're in the moment
yeah
what were some of your favorites the
ones that you were like oh [ __ ] this is
coming next
i love this one battery is always it
okay so if even if we play fight fire
and that but battery is still it because
of the background vocal and because i
matched every [ __ ] thing that the
guitars are playing on bass
all of it yeah the steve harris the
steve harris
with the pit with the pick thing you
know and yeah and following james and
all that kind of stuff which yeah that
that uh the pride of the execution and
being able not to miss anything on such
a challenging number is like a little
shiny part of the crown you know
nice i actually you know when i i got
back and i went on a a clive burr
yeah you know hi hats
just spun down just listening to him and
like uh
really just like i'm kind of like i love
iron maiden and i and i love both
drummers and i love that the band sounds
different
you can hear the difference in both of
them which because they have like these
strong personalities sure so i was
listening to that for the first time i
always knew steve harris was amazing
but that was the first time i just was
really listening and it was like
listening to all of those bass lines it
was never playing off
for the most part what the guitar was
doing it was like what are you doing all
right i'm doing that too and i'm just
gonna add and it's just added this this
density
you know uh
to what they were doing and um
i i don't know just something about you
bringing up battery of having to do that
i never thought about that like if
you're playing with your fingers you can
go faster and if you got like the pick
and then you got those those telephone
cables that you say that you got to keep
up with that so how did that like
uh i don't know how do you even even
like like the first time you're playing
that live
mm-hmm
you gotta be going like okay
here it is stay relaxed
you wouldn't be here
if you couldn't do it
yeah that's right right 80 000 people
yeah it's only being filmed
i get what you're saying try not to
think too much about that i guess but um
you know how you maybe want to have
the end of your show as strong as the
beginning of your show certain jokes
that you know are going to be a home run
yeah you put in your so you finish as
strong as you started that was always
one of my inner mantras as it were
uh to be as strong at the end for the
last ten minutes as i was for the first
ten and so pacing yourself through the
songs and once again lars the sequencing
live helped with that
um but battery was usually at the very
end and so i had to save up that last
bit like leave every single bit on the
stage every single bit i got like you
talk about angus with the flow of sweat
yeah i will i will put up a
competitive uh uh hat in the ring or
whatever like that and that's in that
situation for the that particular thing
for sure what do you think would be
harder to to start with it or
because to start with it you're ice cold
kinda yep and you gotta play at that
speed there's a chance you would like
tense up or is it harder you know to
have played on how long you guys play a
couple hours right and then all of a
sudden it's like all right now that
we've done this full workout and a half
now you're gonna sprint sprint
you know
the last seven miles right and it always
changed too you know a lot of the time
for the early years it would always
start with creeping death a lot and
those kind of things was kind of a
mid-tempo ish bombastic deal
but then sometimes it would start with
black and or something so you had to be
right right from the get-go right out of
the gate
you know so there's i think starting
mid-tempo and by the second or third
song you're kicking fast that's cool you
know but
when lars started
when lars put together those sets did ar
are there scheduled breaks like hey
let's give our forums a break and play
like uh
nothing else matters you know
let's just go
slow it down here everybody you know
work the kinks out and then we'll start
thrashing again yeah i think it was
centered around uh james's vocal thing
and been able to give him a rest for
certain songs and stuff so a bass solo
guitar solo these things where he could
go and sit for a minute or i would take
a vocal for four-minute song or
five-minute song and then he'd be able
to get that seven minutes of rest in his
throat there and nine minutes rest in
his throat there so if you had three or
four of those through the set you can
make it through no problem
but it was always based around the vocal
and keeping that athleticism you know
keeping it fresh and stuff yeah and
that's what i think too like i always
hate when people will say oh you know he
can't hit those notes anymore it's like
you you can't nobody can hit the notes
anymore it's just like your voice
naturally gets lower and this guy is
singing live i'm not saying people say
it about james i'm just saying i'm
talking about like singers like robert
plant used to get [ __ ] for that sure and
so he doesn't sound like he does on the
album it's like dude the guy's doing
like 200 [ __ ] he's doing the immigrants
on 200 shows a year right
you know it's like you know cut the guy
a little bit of uh
a little bit of slack but um yeah and
the track that you're listening to from
the immigrant song original recording he
was 22 or some [ __ ] you know what i mean
so he had all that gold in there in
there and then way before whatever abuse
and the other things that went down and
i think you know the the charisma and
the years and the thing and the age in
the voice for someone like robert plant
now is even more beautiful and
attractive and appealing and cool to
listen to i also like that he just aged
naturally yes dude you know what i mean
he looks [ __ ] great like that's a big
thing with me like you know i'm vain i
try to keep myself in shape but
uh you know in this business you know i
think one of your big goals is to try to
look like a human being when you come
out the other side no doubt as opposed
to uh
some of the [ __ ] that i've uh
yeah some of the stuff that you see
you're like oh my god they get like that
cat face you know what i mean it's like
are you trying to look like a lion like
they get all this filler
in here and they kind of
i don't even know they almost they're
creating like a new race the botox race
god holy [ __ ]
yeah and so you know those uh of our
pals you and me both that
really went for the accelerated
lifestyle uh approach
um and now that they're the calendar
says the same thing for them but the
flesh don't
you know it's like oh boy
there's something you know there's
something to be said
you know as i've g i'm old now i was
just thinking about as far as just like
picking your poison the only only it's
like i don't mind if someone's just
blowing just doing their thing
if they're happy
but it's when they're out of control
that's when it's hard to look at but
some people are just like look man i
like eating burgers and smoking
cigarettes and
what the [ __ ] i like to do and have a
couple glasses of wine it's just like
you know if that makes you happy like
you know you don't need to live those
extra whatever years
you know on a diet being [ __ ]
miserable like you you'd take like 60 62
fun years over 85
being like yeah
no doubt well let's say is there any
salt on those brussels sprouts because
my doctor said
yeah there's a line right you want to
look out for yourself but you also want
to live so it's uh yeah it's tough and
especially when you're out doing what we
do and getting around and everything you
know
yeah it's a little bit what i do is i
just i try to i try to uh
i try to pick some new stupid skill to
learn how to do and i just i focus or
something that i'll get into like uh
you know dean dean del rey he's really
into these mid-century houses and i've
just he just kind of got me into
architecture so i'll just look at that
instead of uh going down to the hotel
bar and being any an idiot but i do know
that when i start when i'm overworked
that's when i start having these
fantasies
of selling everything i own somehow i
sell everything i own but i get to keep
my house and everything in it in the
it's a fantasy
and i just sit on i'm sitting on the
back porch
and i never really talk to anybody ever
again like i start thinking
not like i mean my friends i do but i
just sort of just fade away and i used
to think like
like oh am i losing or whatever i kind
of realized after a while it's like oh
bill this is your brain saying it's
tired and why don't you take like take a
week vacation and make yourself miss
telling jokes or something like that so
yeah i mean but we don't tour the way
you guys do i mean what's your record as
far as like
longest tour like that in justice
peralta you said was what two and a half
years long yeah but but the black record
was the longest one it was it covered 91
through 93. it was it was continuous
so i think in that middle year there i
might have been home for
11 days or 13 days or something
what do you do with mail
like how does that work
yeah usually you just have whether the
management uh in san francisco just gets
everything they just get loaded their
offices just get loaded with [ __ ]
when we're gone you know yeah when we're
going so you spend three years on the
road
you're doing the last show of the tour
is there any melancholy or is it like oh
my god i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
i can't do this again
the
depth of the exhaustion
is
a place that
you
you know any kind of like proper
reasoning skills i just love how you
said that the depth
of the exhaustion i felt the weight of
that
wow you've been able to reason you know
like if
should we go to to the louvre and see
the the painting that is you know that
there are these things are mona lisa
whatever that [ __ ] like actually i'd
like to get three hours of sleep since i
haven't slept since tuesday and now it's
friday um i should probably mona lisa
will still be there when we come back i
got a good feeling overrated by the way
no that's about this big overrated and
then and then there's 5 000 people
standing in front of it with this stupid
[ __ ] phones
and nobody's saying anything that's the
only thing i saw in the louvre i went
right to it yeah i'm like yeah i saw it
and then i went right to a bar and just
started getting shit-faced and i had way
more way more fun doing that the first
time that we went to see that in the 80s
though it wasn't like that and it wasn't
behind all layers of plexiglas and you
couldn't get within 15 feet and all that
you could actually get up on it so that
was i mean i'm glad i did that at that
time but you understand what i'm saying
and you've had to do that certainly too
but there is that time where you get
when you get to the end like that like
we did i think that was fourth of july
um vector belgium and we had just done
one of the coolest shows as a question
from a little bit ago um
back then pink pop
and uh the vector festival we're already
way steps ahead uh in the thinking of
diversity of the bill and the amount the
different genres that we're going to be
there to entertain the crowd and the
um
broader listening practices of the
people in the crowd they came to see all
that if it's good music it's good music
right period right so it started out as
bob muelled sugar
and it was uh
um faith no more and
lenny kravitz and when he was firing bro
you know like really really good man
this oh he still had those dreads and
watching from the side of the stage and
you know that old uh
hendrix footage and bob marley footage
where the dreadlocks are going it's like
that
like animated it becomes like an
animated thing but you're seeing it with
your eyes like this that was fantastic
and then neil young played before us
dude what the [ __ ] is that all about
like as far he should have went after as
far as we're concerned especially from
the bay area and all that thing that's
like you can't what the hell have you
been thinking like with that you know
there's nobody well you know that i
don't think the crowd would right
right right
yes and we had to play by that certainly
because the record was hitting big and
it was a gigantic thing and the 55 000
people that are there or whatever we're
certainly a lot of them to see metallica
but
he kind of put out one of his best
albums harvest moon right around then
was that what he was oh my god yeah i
think it was and and uh in this in his
backing band was booker t and the mgs
okay he said still when duck don is
still playing bass and i mean the the
the
baddest [ __ ] that there ever
was
laying the [ __ ] down live steve cropper
you know who played drums on that do you
remember who was in his band
no i don't but that's the it was the
mg's drum or whatever i'm sorry i don't
know his name um but anyway jackson was
the original guy he he got murdered yeah
it wasn't al jackson no no and i
remember steve jordan would sit in with
them every once in a while
whoever it was i know was a killer
drummer and they got to keep up with it
but the the thing that always got me was
that this particular uh stage was a big
one and i always you know i got my
workout in for sure every show
and if i yeah if they would have had the
goddamn fitbit on me back then thing
would have exploded
so they go
from the edge of the pa over here on the
riser to the edge of the pa and the
riser over here it's 150 feet so a
football field and then it's i mean
how is it 150
is that right 150 feet okay that's fair
enough 150 feet um
and so we would go you know i'd
how many times can i go from end to end
during the show and get all up on the
thing and um
the habit trail and the steps and all
the [ __ ] up on there by the drums
everything uh so we had all that room to
take up but neil and his boys when they
came on before us they brought out their
you know their uh hippie rugs and they
set up in a city and about a
shoot man 30 40 square foot space man
about like this whatever they could fit
on the rugs is how much room they took
up
right and the expanse of the stage going
that way and they span to the stage
going that way open
and they crushed us
they killed wow
you know that i i was like oh you know
the thing about follow that follow that
[ __ ] type of thing that's that's
all i could feel trying to follow that
because of the purity of it and like the
good music factor neil did the crowd no
they responded to him like crazy
oh wow when he because he was playing
electric so he brought that old that
black les paul out that never can stay
in tune and just [ __ ] how he gets
into that lean step it just goes like
trancing out man and they would just
transit man for like seven or ten
minutes it was untouchable yeah we still
came back with our bombs and all our
[ __ ] but i don't think it was as good as
needed
you know but just the diversity of the
flames we did what we had to do we do we
had to do and the kids liked it but i
don't think it was as good as the guys
before us
you brought up uh
bill graham and there was a
what was what was that guy
like what was it like to me i was a
vietnam war vet he just was like
i remember there was there was footage i
can't find it there was this footage i
think that it was a documentary about
him at the fillmore in san francisco and
i remember it was a farewell to the
something or other and this one guy from
one band wanted to play it and he didn't
get put on the bill so he goes down to
bill graham and tries to get on the bill
and when bill graham's just like listen
man it's just not roman then the guy
goes well you know man well you know
then i guess you know [ __ ] off and
thanks for the memories man and then
bill graham just [ __ ] snaps
just snatched like what the [ __ ] did you
just say to him and you see the look on
the guy's face like well i just ended my
music career yes
um and i was just like
seeing the look of horror on that guy's
face is he trying to still be a man but
back down what he just said yes i was
like wow this like to like the level of
power
before the internet that promoters had
yes to make or break you what was when
you're going to meet that guy
like and just the hands i mean if i ever
shook his hand you know we were still
alive i'd be like this hand shook
jimmy's hand
this hand you know shook jim morrison's
hand this hand like all of those
everybody this hand shook everybody's
hand you signed the magic sign the check
for hendrix type of thing yeah yeah what
was it like when you when when you uh
were you intimidating intimate yeah
yeah but but um you're always really i
remember being just on your best
behavior he would come and say hi before
especially the show we spoke of can say
boys you know that kind of thing give us
a smile and give us a thumbs up and that
but a very serious individual when you
are a pioneer and you're inventing it
ain't no [ __ ] can tell you that you
did it wrong
you know i did that first we did it
wrong oh really
right
that kind of thing so if you already got
that in your quiver as your first arrow
type of thing right what i'm saying so
the and and there had been some i would
let the other guys explain to you james
had a real running with him in the early
days and so his thing with metallica
when they finally rose and got somewhere
he was actually extra proud because of
the trouble he had with them earlier
so by the time that we got to somewhere
it was intimidating to be with him but
we were respectful of each other he was
rich do you remember uh are you free to
talk about what the run-in was was it he
was too loud for the band you know
going on after was it a
uh from what i what i know it was an
early show i think it was like 85 and
they were phil moorish must have been
fillmore west uh and uh san francisco
and something with a mic stand that
james threw a mic stand in the crowd
hurt somebody did something and then
perhaps got
uh
you know what do you call that
uh and subordinate or something with uh
with bill about it
so like it's all right yeah about the
right word like where you know like
right like dismissive or something with
bill
afterwards because he was really drunk
and he's punk ass kid full of himself
and he's got his ride the lightning
album out and everybody's kissing his
butt at the moment he doesn't know any
better and he had 13 cursed lights by
the time he got to talk to the man after
he threw the mic stand and hit the kid
in the head what loss what lawsuit's
going to come from it and all the other
[ __ ] that lines up in our business bill
that never ever stops
right the depositions and stuff dude
it's just like
craziness man through time for real is
that well
well fortunately i don't do any of that
type of stuff in my show i just say well
eventually you know it'll it'll happen
somebody will freak out about some
stupid joke and
i guess you'll have some sort of case or
whatever but um there's anyway um
winding down here i like you
moved uh away from where you were at how
i don't want to say where you're at but
like uh
because i you know living in l.a you
know when you were telling me you were
kind of getting out of the hustle and
the bustled you know
my kids are locked into the school
systems here but there's definitely days
you know those days when i think about
just sitting on the porch and not
talking to anybody ever again like
there's days that i think uh and and i
think you know
like man jason moved uh
that kind of sounds like i'm just seeing
those trees and [ __ ] yeah it seems quiet
i mean it must be great for your
creativity and the the music you're
working on now um
now that you are where you are
i'm trying to talk around this uh
you look happy as hell and i'm happy for
you that's what i'm trying to say
thank you bill i appreciate that and
things are going quite well we had a
great jam uh today
um nice and loud and free like we did
you know no no plan just
[ __ ] beautiful noise so we did that
for oh i got to tell people how i met
you i was the writers from
i can't remember if you sent an email or
something
and you were like yeah hey it's jason
man i know you play drums i like your
comedy we should get together and jam
and i was just like
yeah man
that's yeah and then like he's like well
i'm gonna be down there next week and i
was like all right and you and where we
were you picked uh was it s-i-r or as i
called it sir because i'm not sir i
called it sir s-i-r uh rehearsals
and
i just show up and there you are i was
like oh my god hey how are you
and then you proceeded to just play
original um
riffs that you had
and that was it was such an eye-opening
thing to me of how much i sucked on
drums because i didn't realize
that all of these times when i would be
jamming on songs there was songs that
everybody knew and the drummer came up
with the track already so i had the
answers to the test yes all of a sudden
you started playing i was just like uh
boom crack boom crack boom
i think that was it
i thought it was awesome i really did i
did too i mean i was uh
i could i couldn't uh i remember trying
to tell
you know my brothers who wanted to get
me the double pedal i was like you're
not gonna believe this who i jammed with
today they're like oh what the [ __ ]
i like that i like that very much you
know what what is funny about your guys
music is the the [ __ ]
level like with trash music and [ __ ] how
much
like if people are into it like they are
just like i will die for this music and
i remember when i was playing um
i had a gig in boston
and it was a big [ __ ] place so i
rented some drums and my brothers came
into town and we all got down we started
jamming
and you know the security was listening
like whatever whatever whatever and then
we played a slayer song
i think i forget what one we played a
slayer song and the second we played at
this this [ __ ] security guard way up
like two levels up just because slayer
it like freaked out
then we played a few more nobody gave a
[ __ ] and then we did a metallica song
and then another guy yelled out the name
of this song and then all of a sudden
like the whole security like they just
were looking at us like we were a bunch
of dorks but after we played a slayer
and a metallica they were like it was
good man that sounded good you're all
right
all right you want them over you want
them over with the right selections well
you know i think it's i think because of
i think when all of those bands hit and
what you guys went through and how it
was an underground thing and there were
so many people saying to people that
were listening to it like you listen to
this [ __ ] what is this the felt that the
fact that then the metallica album came
at the end they were all vindicated
like i told you this was a great band so
um it's been a ridiculous honor to have
you
on this podcast talking about one of the
great uh rock what greatest rock albums
of all time i can't believe it's been 30
years that's crazy uh are there any more
of those black box things left or did
fans just gobble them up yeah they sold
out in the first i don't know how many
hours or whatever but i don't know if
they're going to print more or what's
going to happen with it but uh
yeah it's i
it's nutty it really is nutty let me
tell you i just a couple things that
blew blew me away with uh
its resurgence as it were when it first
came out in germany enter sandman went
as high as number two it never got
higher
and then three weeks ago or whatever
when it came back on the radio went to a
number one
30 years later
so this kind of i mean what the heck
that's pretty hard to get a hold of but
i want to tell you that i had a couple
of names for the band and i told you our
band
our band our our power duo oh um and uh
yeah look out black keys
yeah exactly so the beginning when we
when we first played i don't know if you
remember not i i was calling it uh
jaybirds right j b u r r d s j birds
right but then yeah but since that time
i've thought a little bit more about it
and so i've taken four your four letters
they take four letters from my name so
bursted right
appendix bursted appendix that's the
name of our band
because appendix doesn't just mean
listening to me play drums is as fun as
a bursted appendix which i had i had an
alarm when i was a kid that's going to
be the tagline on the t-shirt
this this music as is as fun
as that on the back yes
a gig or something in 2022 if you're not
on the road uh in your area so uh i
would love to hang i feel like i haven't
seen i feel like i haven't seen anybody
in forever so um i'm hoping that's gonna
work out but if it doesn't i know that
you're on the road doing what you love
to do so either way it's gonna be
awesome so thank you so much for coming
on and talking about you know one of the
great albums greatest albums of all time
and uh i hope to see you soon all right
yeah thanks bill we're going to come and
see you in west palm and then we'll
probably see up in new york later too oh
nice good deal good deal all right the
great jason neustadt thank you brother
metallica 30 years 30 years anniversary
uh get your copy to keep it on the
charts and have a great weekend you
[ __ ] and i'll talk to you on monday we
got the uh the bet mgm um
picks of the week for you football fans
coming up next
what's up everybody we are back for
another nfl edition of the mg bet mgm
which as you know by now guys we've
teamed up with bet mgm this season we'll
be using bet mgm lines the best lines to
make all of our picks and we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week if you haven't signed up uh
for bet mgm yet
use bonus code burr that's b-u-r-r
and you'll get two hundred dollars free
after placing your first ten dollar bet
here's how it works very simple you
download the bet mgm app you sign up
using bonus code burr that's b-u-r-r
place your first 10 money line bet at
any nfl game okay any nfl game you'll
receive 200
in free bets immediately after placing
your bet regardless of the outcome so
basically bet mgm is saying sign up and
get the app and here's 200 bucks go have
fun okay just make sure you use bonus
code bur b-u-r-r to sign up now but i
have to start off by saying
congratulating
uh my my partner here mr burr
for doing the unimaginable for the we
have the first unimaginable you know
we've had our first unforget uh
unforgivable unfortunately i was on the
wrong side of that
and now
you're on the wrong side of history paul
we now we have our first
uh unimaginable bill going uh four or no
but i gotta give i gotta give bill more
credit
not only did the kid go 4-0 and come
roaring back like the two-time jimmy the
greek champion that he is
taking the lead now by two games i
believe or two and a half with the tie
but then the kid calls a fumble from
chicago to the steelers and i'm in my
car driving home from a gig and i'm
listening and i'm going man i know we
got two out of the three things steelers
still need to win we got three out of
the four and then all of a sudden i hear
oh he fumbled it it is picked up and
pittsburgh has it and i was like [ __ ]
ray liotta in the shower in goodfellas
the son of a [ __ ]
i was so happy so bill big we've picked
two monday night specials in a row what
other podcast with literally paul
putting money yes in their pocket
and i'll tell you this i was a teacher
you went with me this week i went 4-0 on
my picks and i wanted that pats game
that was 5-0 which you picked
and two monday night specials
yeah we're now what you got to do
you got to lay off me
because how long can this streak last
i it really is a game of runs but i got
to tell you something bill touching on
what you just said
i was at skankfest in houston which by
the way man what they created what what
they created is so incredible but people
were coming up to me in the streets
literally coming up to me in the streets
going dude
you guys doing that
you guys doing that bed mgm thing it
like brought me and my dad together
again
we haven't even one guy was like yeah
dude we just sit down and we literally
go with what you guys pick
and like the last two monday night
specials so uh
you know maybe that's hilarious me and
my dad haven't spoken in years what
brought you back together gambling
hey paul you know whatever works you
know i think maybe we're on some cutting
edge level of therapy you know some
people are taking you know low dosages
of mushrooms and uh you know uh molly
whatever the kids call it and uh you
know who knew you could say stone sober
and just be a degenerate gambler
who now all of a sudden you're like dad
[Music]
i want money on the chiefs i remember my
first chief game you took me there
so the standings as they are people were
asked last week uh just double checked
the tally reviewed every pick it's 18
paul's 18 and 18 bill was 20 15 and won
look at that look at us both of us at
500 or above against the spread we're
not doing that [ __ ] money line that
all those other sports team we're we're
doing the real thing paul we're getting
our hands dirty
yes that's true we're messing with their
kids futures here paul yep because a lot
of those nfl analysts on tv the
professionals they go money line now
who do you think is going to win the
[ __ ] bills of the jets bill's at home
i mean come on what are we doing here
paul yeah let's get some [ __ ] let's
people want the real world paul
they want the independent candidate that
dress is like them
think about it
yeah think about this for a second this
doesn't happen that's some hair plug
they want a couple of bald bastards
picking against the spread
and winning and [ __ ] winning winning
[ __ ] winning what's the worst you got
right now
you even
the worst i've been is evil all of these
guys [ __ ] flapping their arms around
going i'm picking you winners paul we're
in november
we're already in the holiday season
hollywood how [ __ ] halloween
halloween's in the [ __ ] rearview
mirror
we got thanksgiving coming up we are a
combined
38 in what
no so we both picked 36 38 like 33 or
something like that well i need you to
step it up what's what's 36 times 2
72 so we've we've we've picked 72 games
and we are above we are 500 or above
dude and actually minus four because we
went head to head so minus four so 68
games and we're above
so dude we are so guys rob you know it's
not the paul i actually earlier this
year when you [ __ ] give me your the
reason why jacksonville was gonna lose i
got into an emotional place and i took
jacksonville so i lost that so you're
one in four
you're one and four head-to-head against
me okay okay well
all i'm saying is our listeners you need
to ride this anything better money train
okay you need to ride this [ __ ] money
train all the way to [ __ ] paul let's
head your bets now
we've been doing so well who knows maybe
maybe they bet the [ __ ] don't pass
bar whatever the pass bar those [ __ ]
are you gonna bet against the shooter
are you coming along for the ride who
would have thought who would have
thought that two comedians
doing a podcast where we [ __ ] around
with sports
who am i who am i who are
we who are we
we are at the top of the sports gambling
world in the nfl take that espn we're
coming for you take that everybody ah
you moneyline [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah the chiefs might squeeze this one
out i got a good feeling about the
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here bet
against the money line i shut your
[ __ ] anderson little suit wearing ass
up all right that brings us to week
number nine
and uh it is a giant eight by the way is
an odd number which means
uh the birthday boy goes first
okay
i gotta tell you paul this this [ __ ]
week feels like 2 a.m at a bar
what am i going home with
who do you like paul
uh hold on i got to get these lines here
he texted him
all right so
actually i know what i know the first
game i'm going to pick as i look for
this because i liked it all week i liked
it all week
i'm gonna go out i'm gonna say right
here and i'm sorry kansas city fans okay
i'm sorry if it's over
the kansas city chiefs
there is either this is what happened
either someone with the cover two with
the safeties did something
somebody's hurt
something is off
something is off we've seen it enough
okay my new york giants had a lot of
people out and almost pulled that off
they did not look good they did not beat
the packers by enough without aaron
rodgers i am taking the las vegas
raiders by the way
it is my homecoming theory the raiders
lost to my giants
now they are coming home
and they are two and a half point dogs
at home he called that you [ __ ]
yourself on that theory
why
you just said that coming home you
didn't say they're a good team coming
home
no the raiders the raiders i know but
you you you said i said a good team
coming them and then when that guy
[ __ ] debunked your theory well they
are still you have that you have a
meltdown paul
there are a few questions
there are a few games over 500 i don't
believe in the chiefs i think the
raiders come home to vegas and beat the
chiefs uh and getting two and a half
that's my first i just want to clarify
your homecoming it's not just a
homecoming you say a good team a good
coming off a road loss that's right
that's right look at me looking out for
you paul that's right you know what you
are looking at
before my
all right um
inexplicably the [ __ ] jacksonville
jaguars won a game last week against the
bills does this mean they go on a run
paul or does this mean that this is just
their [ __ ] highlight of the year i
say it's their highlight of year
the colts are at home they're scoring
points like [ __ ] uh like like [ __ ]
uh uh dominique wilson wilkins back in
the [ __ ] day had to have an obscure
reference there
i'm gonna take the colts given 10 and a
half against the [ __ ] jaguars
you know i think that uh my pretty pony
quarterback i think he's not gonna do
too well there they can be brushing his
hair by the [ __ ] second quarter
am i jealous of his hair yes i am i've
taken the colts and carson wentz mine is
10 and a half at home
that's a good dude i love that you're
taking point you don't get i mean bill's
just taking going after points this year
i love it
bill bill is [ __ ] swinging in the
dark he has no idea i hate this week
paul
yeah uh i hate this week like i hate a
third show on saturday go ahead
you know
i don't know
there's a couple of tough ones here dude
there's a lot of points this week i feel
like this is like a turning point in the
season for teams
i mean look at this minus 10 minus seven
and a half minus eight and a half minus
yeah they're still staying with those
big [ __ ] spreads i was surprised
there's a lot of bills i couldn't
believe the bills are like you know i
know they lost to the jaguars but it's
like [ __ ] what are they 13 15
that's just a lot of points in the
division rivalry yeah jets are getting
13 against the bills
is it in
buffalo uh no it's in new york
or jersey
all right can a giants fan take the jets
paul
this is a tough game i don't know why
i'm gonna take it i'm gonna take it
because the line is low
but i'm going to ride the train i'm
going to take the patriots at home
against the browns you [ __ ] you
can't do that to me two weeks in a row
you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you want
you [ __ ] [ __ ] where the [ __ ] do
you get off i don't pick the [ __ ]
giant you [ __ ]
i knew i should have picked them first
bill belichick in november go [ __ ]
yourself
you [ __ ] two [ __ ] weeks in a
row you call yourself a friend
you i didn't know you lot you cared
about you call yourself a friend two
weeks in a row you take my pets
come on
what do you mean come on paul versus
swinging in the dark desperate for a
victory jumps on the bill belichick mack
jones train you [ __ ] i had the first
cherry picker you cherry picked a son of
a [ __ ] that's not there's a reason
you're wearing yellow this week
you're [ __ ]
i giants
the raiders first you had a chance you
picked the colts you could have taken a
picture i thought you were a gentleman
you wouldn't do it two weeks in a row i
guess i was wrong
oh so now i can't pick your team i mean
i don't care if you pick the giants
why would you they stink
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
minus two at home against the browns who
have fallen apart jesus paul walk up to
the buffet table and fill up your plate
plate don't you
it's a great piece you
[ __ ] dirty bastard
well i gotta pick the patriots first
every week now paul's on the patch train
i picked this the second time i ever
taken them the whole year
but it's it's becoming a habit with you
this is the only second time i've only
taken them once
you took them twice
no now this is dude you need a victory
that's what it is paul's desperate
that's a desperate move
oh paulie you win some you lose some old
500.
you [ __ ] bastard all right uh
i knew you were gonna do that
all right i'm taking seattle on the road
versus green bay
russell wilson's coming back
sneaky pete's gonna go in there i just
feel like they're they're more organized
um
you know aaron rodgers is coming back
i like i always like him at home but
there's just something about
i don't know earlier this year
he was unhappy with how the whole
franchise was running
and i thought he was making a great
point like a mom-and-pop organization i
don't even know who makes the decisions
over there this isn't against aaron
rodgers but uh i do think the added
distraction of his uh
you know what covet [ __ ] i just i
just i like seattle
plus three and a half getting three and
a half points i love russell wilson d.k
metcalf
and sneaky pete i think he's a great
coach and he's a better coach than
whatever the [ __ ] green bay has
should i take that head to head
paul i don't give a [ __ ] what you do
after you took my pets twice in a row
what a [ __ ] god damn it
um you sneaky bastard
you goddamn sneak
i'm gonna take it
i'm gonna take the tennessee titans
minus three at home against uh new
orleans saints now i got now i gotta go
look for another [ __ ] game that i've
ever been wanting on a on a difficult
week
do you know what i was like i'm watching
the pants and i'm also thinking paul's
getting a victory here why would you do
that to me
bill you could have picked them first
you picked the colts
paul that's
paul you could have not picked him two
weeks in a row
oh my so i should so so you you
should have been a gentleman
oh we're doing a phone you know what
you're doing paul
paul there's unwritten rules there's
unwritten rules in this [ __ ]
i gotta wat now i'm watching my team
rooting for them and brooding for a
[ __ ] guy that's going to get a
victory in our head-to-head
i see i don't obviously you take it more
i have to break that down for you no i
get what you're saying but like that's
not i come over your house you gotta
spread out and i double dip right in
front of your wife and kids that's okay
the family in the world are you living
it you're double dipping paul you're
double dipping you're sticking your chip
in after you had it in your mouth two
weeks in a [ __ ] row in the guacamole
too the favorite dip of everybody
the patriots in november
there's a reason you're wearing yellow
this week that's all that's a cowardly
[ __ ] paul's flailing
all right i'm going to take kyla murray
coming back
they're at home they're playing the
hapless carolina panthers who are trying
to
erase
they're trying to erase the whole
history
of former patriot quarterback
an auburn star for some reason i can't
remember his [ __ ] name right now why
can't i remember his [ __ ]
who's your guy paul
cam newton
yeah cam newton i was thinking dax
shepard i might i'm too [ __ ] old here
cam newton they're racing the guy's
memory it's just bad [ __ ] karma it
really killed my point that i couldn't
remember his name there
cam newton i mean come on isn't dak
shepard like a celebrity like an actor
or something
that's hilarious i thought that was the
quarterback of the cowboys isn't
comedian no
shepherd is like
married to kristen bell he's a [ __ ]
actor you're thinking of dak prescott
oh okay
i mean whatever paul i'm not picking the
[ __ ] giants and ruining your
thanksgiving you could pick i'll take
i'll take the canopy yeah we're defended
paul defending you know coming to
another man's stadium and take his
[ __ ] team so he like there's a part
of me that can't enjoy that they're
gonna win
because you're getting a win that's what
you're doing to me paul
i didn't know that these were the rules
oh you're walking into my house with
muddy shoes on right on the carpet no no
no you if you love your team go with
them first
you had the first pick and you picked
the colts
because i thought you weren't gonna do
that to me two weeks in a row and i
thought you'd love the colts
i wouldn't i'm not doing it up like i'm
looking at the games i like
no
scumbag [ __ ] move no it's not it
would have been a scum it is paul it is
not a scholar i have to watch my team
win and know that you're getting a
victory
why would you do that to me well it's a
holiday month do that to me in september
first of all thanksgiving's my favorite
holiday and you're eating off my plate
two weeks in a [ __ ] row
thanksgiving's overrated
thanksgiving's
why is it overrated because you just sit
you get [ __ ] fat you sit down you
fall asleep christmas is about spirit
about the children being happy getting
gifts oh is it give your wife's spirit
for christmas and see how she [ __ ]
likes that
it's not what it's about it's about
going out and buying some big stupid
[ __ ] bag you didn't want to buy just
to shut him up until valentine's day
that's what it's about you know what i
love about [ __ ] thanksgiving paul
you're not required to do anything you
put on a sweater you watch the lions
lose
you know you look at the hapless [ __ ]
cowboys and you tune out your relatives
while you eat delicious food paul you
love to eat there's always automatic
because it's not built around pasta
yeah [ __ ]
yeah something wrapped in a [ __ ]
great leaf
there's always that relative at
thanksgiving that you gotta worry about
what they're gonna say in front of
people man [ __ ] that's on you paul
that's on you you're the bouncer in your
own house
considering you don't mind barging into
mine and picking my patriots two [ __ ]
weeks in a row you [ __ ] turn coach
son of a [ __ ]
paul what i've always liked about you is
you had class oh stop it man as much as
you dress like a third grader waiting
for a bus on the first day of school
[Music]
i swear to god you want to laugh i put
this on today and as i put this on i
remembered my yellow sweatpants when i
was in grade school
so you look like a school bus yeah
all right now what am i doing here so
i'm trying to [ __ ] kill time here so
i can pull another pick out of my ass
here no i think you did
no i well i i got i just had it now now
it's your pick but now i got i got to go
on and try and find something here paul
all right so this would be my last
you've got to understand i look at these
picks for a good 30 seconds the amount
of work that's put into this
i'll go ahead and i'll go head-to-head
with you to take the
take the packers
let me take the packers minus three and
a half rogers coming back
i'll look at you now acting like you're
a hero
what do you mean
i like that pick
exactly
kid's coming back with a bad finger gets
hit in a finger you know
[Laughter]
right there paul everybody heard how
much thought is behind our picks
a kid comes back with a bad finger he
gets hit in the finger
that's the kind of analysis you get here
on the anything better podcast all right
i got the [ __ ] lines in front of me
here paul i'm trying to pick because
once again paul versi walks into my
house doesn't even say hello
sits down in my chair and starts [ __ ]
eating before anybody else sits at the
table
good lord
um
oh the bills are only 13.
am i gonna take the [ __ ] jets what am
i an [ __ ] you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna take the [ __ ] buccaneers
laying nine and a half
against the team from washington
how funny is it that they just can't
come up with a [ __ ] name
they're really just saying
they're really making a statement paul
uh andrew you got our picks right
we got four each
all right everybody
well
you know paul i want extra credit that
last week i went four no despite the
fact you took my patriots
we're not gonna you no no we can't i
[ __ ] just gave you all the credit in
the world for going 4-0 your fumble
thing and i thanked you and i wish you a
happy birthday and then what did you do
paul
you didn't even knock
you put your air jordans right on my
french door you kicked
kicked the [ __ ] door open
i love that that patriots pick was my
[ __ ] warm blanket for the week going
okay as much as i hate this week i know
i'll get one i'll get one i might do the
un un
unforgivable paul dude you you were that
confident in that dude the the browns
just won
i was like hesitant about that pick you
you love you you got a guarantee on that
pic whenever you're full of [ __ ] you
start squinting your eyes
no i was looking
all right yeah i'm squinting my eyes
because i'm [ __ ] losing my sight i'm
getting old here and i got to do this
offer um anyway
monday night special oh monday night
special
guys let them monday nights paul you
know what i'm gonna let the bad blood
between us die here
because now i have to team up with you
i'm going to go old-school politician
here and reach across the aisle to my
nemesis
who came in and peed on my rug this week
[Laughter]
oh my door is i can't even laugh um guys
what's gonna happen paul you're gonna
lay off the pats next week and i'm gonna
pick them they're gonna lose um
guys we hit the monday night special for
you not once in a row but two times in a
row and i know you can't i know once not
on the money line either paul not on the
money line and one we've picked seven
straight things in a row that we're
going to happen and we picked mahomes to
throw an interception and
one team getting a fumble and then the
other team getting it and we hit them
both okay we're making people money as
we patting ourselves on the back
all right let's let's do let's do our
monday night special as the great club
soda kenny would say we're making money
moves
[Laughter]
all right so the monday night game this
this week is the los angeles rams versus
the san francisco 49ers is that right
correct bet mgm has the niners getting
four the best lines bet mgm lines have
have the niners getting four in san
francisco is that right correct
oh bill what monday night special are we
gonna do here's one i like well here's
something you should know
all right
the san francisco 49ers have not won at
home in like i think that was their 13th
game going back to last year
how many times
can you lose at home i know they got a
bunch of guys out i went to the game
last week
colt mccoy came in there and had his way
with him
the rams are coming off a loss andrew is
that right
the rams are coming off a loss dude
but how about this by the way dude you
you crushed that uh cardinals game
i think one thing we need to do is a
special teams bet on this one i say one
missed kick
can we do one missed kick whether it's a
pat or a field goal either team yeah
miss kiki for sure that's that's not
that's not
crazy we're getting a little cocky all
right i thought you're gonna go miss
mixed extra point i was like jesus paul
no no any kick any missed kick i was
going for the half court dagger during
the third quarter
i'll make sure that it can be for any
team but if you want to pick a team just
in case they can't produce lines on any
team missing
um
do we even know who their field goal
kickers are paul
yeah has it stopped us before no i know
the san fran kid i mean listen they're
all
let's find andrew find out if you know
what i like to you know i went to a rams
tampa bay game this year
and their defense at least in september
looked pretty impressive to me and i saw
the 49ers last week
and uh you know i'm gonna be i'll be
honest with you
you know the cardinals defense forced a
couple of turnovers that was huge that
really could have turned the game or
swung the game back around the other way
um i'm trying to think i don't know the
random i think of matt gay and i'm
pretty sure robbie gould doesn't hurt or
anything so i'm double checking that
yeah
yeah it's it's cool it's cool
matt gay's a good kicker though think
about the rams is i just don't like how
they got rid of their quarterback i just
don't like their coach didn't go face to
face with them if that's a true story
there's something about that paul
it's like your buddy taking your own
team [ __ ] two weeks in a row just
rubs you the wrong way
you wanna
paul i'm mad at myself that's what it
really is that i left it on the table
for you to [ __ ] scoop up
like a fumble and run it into the end
zone
i would yeah i mean look
i i would i didn't do it first and you
didn't do it so then i was like i gotta
do it
what can you i didn't do it first has
got to be the worst [ __ ] excuse i've
ever heard in my life i'm not the first
guy that shot someone in the head you
know
i mean people get murdered every day
um what what are we thinking moneyline
rams
niners
who you got
i mean
i mean it's a tough game to pick on a
money line like this let's just take the
ramps i think the 49ers the wheels are
off and they suck
uh let's let's do i don't think they
suck i just think that they're that
right now is a good time to bet against
them statistically garoppolo is like the
worst quarterback starting quarterback
in the league right now
so isn't he greek
nice italian
italian italian
paul you gonna sit there and take that
i mean half you should be pretty [ __ ]
upset right now
do you want to do what do you want to do
do you want to do like cooper cup
getting six catches dude jimmy the gen
cooper cup over 100 over 100 yards for
something oh yeah that guy yeah
what does that [ __ ] pay like you're
gonna bet 400 is to make 20. how about
how about cooper cup six receptions or
more
i like that
ram's money line
cooper cup miss field goal let's stop
there
yeah we're going to do something
i think we just say a missed field goal
but either time
so cooper cub gets six catches that
brings odds up a little bit that's a lot
that's a lot cooper cub gets six catches
the rams win on the money line and there
will be a missed field goal in the game
that's fine yeah you know what that is
paul that last one that's that one of
those intangibles
yeah
yeah i still think the best as you said
that [ __ ] mahomes was gonna throw a
pick i mean who says that paul i think
you guys got a lot kind of guy that
walks into your house all right i'm
letting it go you guys got a lot of [ __ ]
for the mayhem thing because he was
averaging like one interception a game
and so they were saying that's really
not that crazy maybe last year it would
have been i'm just letting you know yeah
you know don't people always do that
isn't there always some [ __ ] saying
something
like you know what i binge watched on
the plane i watched wall street w-a-h-l
and it was about mark wahlberg who was
already a multi-millionaire as an actor
right but instead he's trying to expand
his world and you watch this guy you
know get all of his different businesses
and dealing with the pandemic i loved it
right
i go on the internet seeing how the
reviews were
and and you know and the reviews in
general were good but there's always a
couple people
really do i really need to sit and watch
this [ __ ] i go i get it i get it he's a
movie star he works out he looks great
there wasn't one moment in there where
the guy's being an [ __ ] it's like how
could you [ __ ] not like this
yeah
that's my pick of the week to get
inspired
like dude this this is there a war on
self-made men all of a sudden here in
this country
yes
the guy that guy grew up in a huge
family
he had a dream he went after it he made
it happen
i mean just the storyline alone he meets
this woman who has her own grocery store
in portland he just likes her he likes
the way she's doing her business he's
got a good heart like i'm telling you
that is like right in the crosshairs of
[ __ ] on the internet that they're not
going to like it
uh your heart's in the wrong place if
you don't enjoy it i really liked it and
i got inspired i'm going to expand my
business paul
yeah let's actually i want to let's
[ __ ]
yellow hoodies
for the person in your life who you know
would when push comes to shove would
pick your team
that way you never forget you dress them
all in yellow
here he
comes you know he's taking the last
deviled egg you're gonna be you're gonna
be on this until next week oh my god no
i'm not that's my pick of the week
though watch uh uh i've been to it's six
episodes wall street it's really
fascinating because it right is the
pandemic hits and he's trying to start
all of these businesses uh it's kind of
stressful
all right uh so that parlay won't work
because you can't do odds against nobody
getting a field goal so real quick if
you guys and cooper cups uh usually
averages seven and a half catches so if
you want to make it like above 10
because it's just not going to pay out
it's below that so it'll be negative
money so it's got to be like
on all right all right so all right so
for the monday night special we'll do
rams money line you want to do cooper
can we do cooper cup like you said 100
yards receiving
yeah that's
he averages right around there so you'd
want to do like over
you know
over a hundred he's not gonna have he's
not gonna have ten catches cooper cup is
not gonna have ten catches
will he have 140 yards no he's averaging
seven and a half
so 49ers defense paul is decimated
does the 49ers defense double up on
cooper cup because he's the best [ __ ]
receiver in football probably i don't
think he's going to get 10 10 catches
um you wanna how about this you wanna do
matt stafford throws three touchdowns
it's fun that's a lot
all right
i don't like to solve a sudden now we
gotta [ __ ] we're such idiots who like
who who [ __ ] averages seven and
catches
he's gonna get six
someone's gonna miss a field goal we
were way off
can't bet on any of that um
all right we got the rams in the money
line yup
um
[ __ ] that i don't give a [ __ ] if they do
double cover him i think he gets nine
catches i do
nine
nine he gets nine catches
and uh
jimmy g throws a pick
that's probably low odds
all right let's do it i mean nine
catches is a lot
but all right
hey paul i bet you're sticky gets nine
side bet he's averaging seven and a half
you want to do eight just to make we
we're trying to make people money
well that's why you want to do like math
yeah you want to go a little higher paul
dude that defense [ __ ] stinks all
right nine catches all right nine
catches jimmy g three so you can feel
better about it paul i'll take that
action if you want to come at me come at
me paul i'm sitting right here what are
you gonna do
i mean now that means i'm betting
against the people but i don't think
he's gonna have nine catches
we'll talk
we'll talk i'll i'll go with the [ __ ]
holiday season here paul yeah i don't
want to be the guy that walks up to the
crabs table and bets on everybody to
crap out so i'll go with it nine catches
uh rams money line and jimmy g throws a
pick you got me betting on it all right
and if he doesn't get nine catches i'll
get you a [ __ ] cigar and i'll sing
i'm sorry by by [ __ ] peggy lee to all
the [ __ ] listeners if it doesn't come
in i know why you want me to make an
italian throw a pick because you're
still mad at me about the new england
thing
is that what that's about
you want me to have an italian throw a
pick it's it's a subconscious thing
so wait a minute so it's okay for you to
be emotional about that but i can't
protect my own team
yeah
we both can be emotional it's totally
fine
so you what do you we'll wait so what do
you want you want jimmy g throws a pick
or no yeah
because your gut said that and i like it
i think that'll happen
i see the pain i'm bringing to your face
paul i don't want to do that
he's a good-looking italian kid i like
the kid what are you gonna do but you
know what everybody has a bad throw
every once in a while
and he's going against a good defense
and he might be desperate because they
might be down points so he may have to
force a little ball in there all of a
sudden it's tipped at the line of
scrimmage and the rams get a pick maybe
late in the game i like it
which gives cooper cup another chance to
go and get a couple more catches and
everybody [ __ ] wins i like it there
you go all right we got it
let the monday night special if we get
three in a row mgm better send something
they're gonna have to shut us down
all right guys so those are our week
nine picks uh hope you enjoy it also
joining us for the monday night special
get bill give him the song again i
always think about you doing that oh
yeah let the monday night special
uh put some money in your pocket because
we picked two weeks in a row better
money train right to the [ __ ] bank
guys with uh obviously bet mgm as you
guys know as we've been talking about
we've teamed up with bet mgm this season
we're using their lines the best lines
the bet mgm lines to make all of our
picks and um we'll have special offers
for our listeners each week
if you haven't signed up for bet mgm yet
just go to bet mgm app okay use the
bonus code burr that's b-u-r-r you'll
get two hundred dollars free after
placing your first ten dollar bet here's
how it works you download the bet mgm
app you sign up using a bonus code bur
couldn't be easier b-u-r-r then you're
in then you place your first bet 10
money line bet on any nfl game you'll
receive 200 in free bets immediately
after placing your bet regardless of the
outcome that's incredible just make sure
you regardless freddy soto rest in peace
uh
rest in peace rest assault just make
sure you use bonus code burr when you
sign up with bet mgm and i am i'm a
little under the weather i'm using my
bed mgm thermos here it's been amazing
we're in front of the camera paul
you have to be 21 years of age or older
to wager in arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis michigan minnesota new
jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia or wyoming only
uh new customer offer paid in free bets
visit bet mgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for arizona uh
800-522-4700 for colorado dc nevada
wyoming and virginia
800-270-7117 for confidential help
michigan 1-800 gambler indianapolis new
jersey pennsylvania west virginia 1-800
bets off for iowa call or text the
tennessee red line
800-889-9789 for tennessee or call
888-777-96964 minnesota
uh sports betting is a void in georgia
hawaii ohio and utah and other states uh
were prohibited uh promotional offers
not available in nevada
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday november 11th
2013. how's it going jode
you know guess who got his uh boston red
sox
championship hat the other day this guy
this guy right here
oh i was there from october 7th on
i'll tell you
the mental anguish that i went through
as a fan over those 23 days
whatever the [ __ ] it took them to win it
but um
i gotta tell you i i actually don't like
the hat
it's it just makes me feel old when i
look at it it just used to just be the
bee and then it'd be like 2013 champions
that's all you needed
now they got they got the [ __ ] trophy
spinning out to the right the bees over
here it's a [ __ ] mess
you know
i don't know
i just look i like i you know what i
look like when i put it on i look like
uh
i'm trying to start a a rapping career
[Laughter]
can i have the middle aged white guy
our team won a championship and i kind
of sucked in gym class
but goddamn and i had heart
white dude hat can they make one of
those
i don't [ __ ] know
oh i don't know anyways i'm um
you know not [ __ ] on that you know
thought that style of a hat i'm just
saying it just looks dumb
on my head
you know
i'm white
of course i observe sports
why would you pick me
i am right where i'm supposed to be in
the stadium i'm sitting in the stands
how about having a little consideration
for a a rapidly aging
balding slow red-headed white dude
and give me a nice boring hat
what am i [ __ ] ashton kutcher
is that an old reference i mean that
fucker's in his 30 by now i don't know
what happened in the last 10 years but
i've noticed it in my act when i go to
make references i think i brought this
up before i was doing a college gig
so i'm up there i'm trying to be hip
i'm trying to be down
i don't know what i was doing and i i
made a reference i needed a reference
for
you know a young pop
skanky kind of chick and i i threw out
britney spears and dude i'm telling you
absolute [ __ ] crickets i got nothing
on it
and then i just did the math quickly in
my head i'm like wait a minute britney
spears is like a 32 33 year old divorced
mother of two at this point
she's not that eighteen seventeen
eighteen-year-old girl coming on guys
i pop my [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] she's
saying in her little [ __ ] outfit
you know total entrapment
hey once she's of age can you still go
back and jerk off to that video or is
that still looking at kitty porn
[Laughter]
look i know in the video she's 17 but
right now she's 26 so even if you split
the difference she's like 23 right
um
anyway so then i had to like
i made a reference i i did damirera's
podcast and we were talking about he
busted me when i i did oh maybe it was
in his podcast i did i did his stand-up
show down at the laugh factory the world
famous laugh factory everybody
all right and if you're around the world
and you've never heard of the world
famous laugh factory then i i think you
need to become a little more
cosmopolitan a little more worldly
okay you got the great wall of china
you got the octet off
and you have the world famous laugh
factory on sunset strip
all right
run by the always lovely
jamie masada and i was down there doing
a stand-up thing and dom has this cool
show where like you know you do stand up
and then after you're done he comes up
and he does these interviews which is
more you just sit there breaking each
other's balls and laughing your ass off
so he called me out
on um
dustin off some old topical material but
i forget how i dropped into it
um i i i did the whole oh speaking of
this you know what's up with monica
lewinsky i mean it wasn't that bad but
it was one of those deals where he
busted me and i laughed about it and i
and i was i was reminded this time
in like the early 2000s i was working
with this [ __ ] hack
and he was on stage and he just goes i
don't know where he goes you know
people are still talking about oj
he just the oj simpson trial was in 90
ha the death of murder happened in june
and the trial concluded in october of 95
and it was 2002 and this guy goes people
are still talking about oj seven [ __ ]
years later and then he proceeds to do
material
that wasn't seven years after the case
kind of thing it was like this was [ __ ]
that he wrote while the trial was going
on
and anyway so i go to tell that story
and i'm at the laugh factory and it's a
crowd of 20 somethings and i tell it to
dom
and i want to say dom left but it got
nothing
from the crowd
and then i'm just looking going all
right say like the average person here
is 24. that means they were born in 1989
that means oj
you know i shouldn't even see me he got
acquitted right i never understood that
case he got acquitted but he still had
to give everybody all his stuff
like they need more evidence to send you
to jail for life
but you know
to get all his stuff including his
heisman trophy all the other side just
has to be i mean come on yeah i mean you
know he did who else who else would have
done it
and then it's like
you know the end of the uh wheel of
fortune you're just like all right first
slicing my daughter's throat i'll take
the dinette set for 700.
that's disgusting bill it was a
disgusting joke oh [ __ ] you i got an
hour to fill here talking to myself
huh what would you be talking about six
and a half minutes in exactly
okay so sit back down in your plastic
staples chair and you put your head down
in your desk inside of your [ __ ]
cubicle i don't hear another word out of
you for the next [ __ ] 53 and a half
minutes
okay
i'm in no mood
i got a long podcast ahead of me and the
last thing i need is someone like you
getting all [ __ ] up in here next to
your stapler
anyways
yeah so i'm starting to feel my age
i mean i look i look phenomenal
despite the top of my dome from just
below my hairline down for my age i look
phenomenal
[Laughter]
i do [ __ ] you i look great
all right i've seen other 45 year olds
it's not a pretty sight
and maybe it's because they got married
and they had a bunch of kids right and
they made them some omelettes and the
kids didn't finish it because they
didn't have teeth yet so then you got to
eat their omelets too and then you start
walking sideways out of your house just
do a gm right
you just start using momentum to get to
your car
you know
you put your belly right on the [ __ ]
driver's side door leaning against it
you know
like a heavyweight fighter trying to
wear down his opponent you're just
leaning against your car as you're
fiddling around trying to find your keys
in your pocket you literally have to
take a break
from carrying that bacon egg and cheese
mass right in front of you
[ __ ] suspension digging in
on the opposite side of the car like
when i try to tip my dog over
you know
i don't know how difficult cow tipping
is but trying to tip over a pit bull is
practically impossible they get low and
they put two of their bionic [ __ ]
legs on the opposite side of their body
and then they also have like webbed toes
and they just dig into the carpet isn't
that right cleo
huh
dude i gotta put up this video of her
snoring
the other night last night
she sounded like a [ __ ] trucker who
just got back from a [ __ ]
there and back trip across the country
full of hobbies
laying on her back
[ __ ] face twitching rem sleep and
just snoring
i don't know i don't think she got sleep
apnea i don't know what a deal is i
[ __ ] love her though so anyways
the hell was i just talking about oh yes
uh looking good for my age but um i'm
starting to feel it feeling it with the
references
so the other day i was working um
what the hell was i had an unbelievable
weekend i worked uh
dc new york in philly
and i'm i'm backstage
in uh in new york city at the beacon
theater
all right legendary
um just beyond anything i ever thought
about i used to go to stand-up new york
on the upper west side and my whole
[ __ ] thing was just being able to get
a spot there
first on a weekday a scheduled spot not
to get thrown up to actually have my
name on the schedule he has a 10 20
right and then it became can i do a
weekend spot but i i and you know i get
off the subway and i'd walk by that
theater a zillion times and it never
even dawned on me
that a comedian could even [ __ ] play
a place like that that's how far away
that was so
um i hope if you were in the area you
had a chance to come down there because
um
both of those shows
were uh
i don't know that was something else
something else uh right up there with
carnegie or any of those other things
and uh but there was something about the
beacon
that just it felt like uh i don't know
felt like i was at the cellar like
comfortable was awesome
so anyways
not jesus christ i forgot what the [ __ ]
i was talking about
all right let's back it up it's how my
brain works it goes in a straight line
so i gotta you know like when you miss
an exit you get a backup back in the day
and you'd go back and look at the side
back of the car up or maybe you just
pulled over and your dad got out all
pissed off
and left his family of five sitting on
the side of the road waiting to be
rear-ended well people didn't text when
they drove back then so i guess it was
normal
right
um ah [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was i talking
about
i can't remember i literally cannot
remember anything that i said before no
wait i said a bad joke
oj
dinette said
ah christ
and there it is and then and then it
just hits the [ __ ] beach and now here
we are we're we're we're in a [ __ ]
lull
i guess i was talking about eating like
[ __ ]
you know i was doing so well
i got myself down to about a buck 70.
you know
i'm watching that ufc the ultimate
fighter right i'm watching that this
season everybody on this show is in
shape
the women are [ __ ] taking it to the
next level they're having some of the
best fights of the season
and it's making me want to work out and
then i went on the road and this is a
funny thing me i i went out with versi
right and we're not drinking right now
we're on the wagon
although i drank wednesday and thursday
but i'm still i still consider on the
wagon wednesday i got [ __ ] up
and i paid for it the whole day and i
was like this is stupid i gotta how many
times do i have to learn
this lesson
um
oh i gotta tell you guys i
i went to the rangers game
the rangers penguins game on uh
what was that wednesday night i gotta
tell you what what a [ __ ] venue
you know they redid the whole thing
seriously after going to a the clippers
warriors game just being in the staples
center because i really love la and i
don't look at the people like that
plastic phony or that type of [ __ ] but i
got to tell you you haven't gone to that
game sunday night and then gone to
madison square garden
uh just you could not compare the
atmospheres
it was just [ __ ] i thought can i stop
saying that annoying word
the atmosphere inside of standing was
just it was electric
yeah you could feel there was something
palpable
in the air the the
pirate victory that was to come um
sounds [ __ ] amazing
there's just nothing like being in a
stadium
watching a team that has a history
albeit a tragic one but has a history
and everybody just grew up watching them
and they know the history of the game
there's rivalries you just you feel it
you know it's like a uh
it's like one of those home-cooked meals
that gets better every time you reheat
it you know like a beef stew
a gumbo
let's throw that out there for the
wonderful people down there in new
orleans
i actually got homesick you know last
night when i watched a little bit of the
saints cowboys i watched a little bit of
the saints cowboys game and um when they
they were shooting down the street
you know they always play that new
orleans music and [ __ ] and uh
al michaels are going i was sitting
there talking about how they were
shooting right down canal street and i
stayed there at the hotel there was the
hotel there's the [ __ ] harrah's
there's a cigar bar and i missed it
but i got to tell you i ended up
shutting off the game
because i was so tired and i what did i
ended up watching this documentary on dr
j on the nba channel you guys got to see
it
of course i don't know the name of it
but uh
just uh they they don't
never made one like that never again
before or after just the combination
that guy was so [ __ ] cool and so
classy and even to this day you want to
talk about a guy aging well
you know
they said that he uh
he can still dunk
and i'm not going to say whether or not
he proves that he can still do it but
you definitely should watch
the documentary of the [ __ ] that the guy
was doing especially all you guys from
the jordan era or maybe the kobe era who
just went just as far back as michael
jordan if you want to know
how michael existed or whatever it's
because he got to i mean aside from
obviously all his hard work and all that
type of stuff but he he got to
watch a guy like like dr j and uh
they showed all the classic [ __ ] his
dunk on michael cooper
um
and then that one where in the 1980s
finals when he drives baseline
jumps up in the air and he's got the
ball
i think maybe in the third row
sort of doing this sort of windmill
thing
swooping around
and he's literally his momentum carries
him out of bounds there's some giant
white dude and i don't know if it was
kareem or who else
just completely
took away that side of the rim
it was over
so anybody else even an all-star maybe
the best they could do
is maybe look to see find somebody open
underneath the basket to pass it to him
or do the playground thing where you try
to throw it off a defensive player and
it's out on them
right but instead he just keeps flying
through the air
all right there's two tall people
blocking this side of the rim i think
i'll just keep gliding through the air
i'm starting to come down so i'll pull
my legs up a little bit give me give
myself a little more hang time comes
back all the way to the other side of
the basket
everything but probably you know his
halfway to his right forearm
down to the tip of his fingers
is out of bounds the other way
and he just reaches back inbounds at the
last second and puts like a reverse spin
on the ball
for a reverse layup on the other side i
can't explain and it goes by so [ __ ]
fast you have to watch it in slow motion
um
they got that they got all the aba
highlights and the stuff they were
giving away like they had a dollar night
or something like that at nassau
coliseum with a new york nets plate when
he was in the aba and it was a dollar a
ticket 9 000 people showed up and if you
showed up not only was your ticket only
a dollar they gave away a free loaf of
bread
so then you start to see all that all
that will ferrell semi-pro stuff it's
just it's awesome man i'm actually
looking it up right now dr j
documentary
um
i guess it's just called the doctor
watch nba tv's the doctor full
documentary uh jesus christ it's already
up online there's [ __ ] sons of
[ __ ] definitely check it out and then
they got all his awesome commercials
um with all the [ __ ] 70s music they
had this one that goes hey hey dr j
where'd you get those moves you move
with such grace are you a member of the
human race
they literally go are you a member of
the human race like you'd political
correctness
would never let you get away from that
with the underlying racist comments what
they were really trying to say was we've
never seen anybody
play like that but you know those aryan
[ __ ]
of course would be like you know
that's exactly what we were saying right
i guess the nazi guys would talk like
that right
do you actually have like a bad german
accent like i just did but you got to
see it but you got to watch that
commercial i'm going to put a link up
for that because then the dude the
second verse that they don't show in the
documentary he goes up into that [ __ ]
70s falsetto
it's the [ __ ] neal loved it she like was
like memorizing the song i was walking
around our house singing it last night
um which is why i love her
all right so there's that so definitely
check out uh the doctor on the nba
channel watch it on the nba channel all
right help out that zillion dollar
business
with their mobbed up refs
[Laughter]
so anyways where the hell are we oh my
god where did the last [ __ ] 12
minutes go it just really flies by when
you're having fun okay time to do a
little bit of advertising
all right everybody here we go bill's
gonna try to read out loud once again
this week is there any improvement
any improvement ah [ __ ] i'm already
throwing it off the rails all right here
we go focusing taking our time relaxing
maybe going a little slower letting it
breathe
dollar shave club everyone for a couple
of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door
not only does it save you a ton of cash
it saves you from trudging to the
drugstore for a pack of blades
i always get stuck behind the lady
paying with all the loose change from
the cat from the car ashtray actually
that's not true i get i get stuck behind
the people who want to not only
buy some uh
i don't know stuff for their dentures
they also want to develop some film
and buy some ice cream and the place i
go to you know only has like two
employees so that one person has to do
all of it so that's that's who i get
stuck behind but let's pretend it is me
it's like she thinks exact change is a
requirement i'm a patient person but
heck
i came in with
with scruff now i'm leaving with the
full beard but now with dollar shave
club for just a couple of bucks a month
amazing quality razor blades are
delivered right to your door that's
right no more wasting time and no more
getting hit up for 20 bucks every time
you buy raises everybody here is getting
their dollar shave club blades and you
should too and here's a genius idea try
replacing your old shaving cream with dr
carvey's easy shave butter from the
dollarshaveclub.com
trust me your face will thank you later
don't waste time at the drugstore behind
the lady paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.comforwardslashburr or
go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
high
shave time shave money go to
dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr
all right just for the record i think i
screwed up three times that's not bad
let's see if i can drop my this is like
golfing see if i can take a stroke off
on this one
e-voice if you are an entrepreneur two
things keep you up at night increasing
revenue and controlling expenses
what about the gold digging [ __ ]
sleeping next to you
um e-voice is a simple technology that
helps you do both how let's start with
revenue e-voice helps you make sure that
everyone who calls your business is
treated like gold you get your own
toll-free or local number you can set up
a dial by name directory or have calls
instantly routed anywhere your cell
phone your house your partner or
assistant or all of the above evoice
even transcribes your voicemails and
emails them directly to you so you can
prioritize when and how to respond
without interrupting your workflow with
e-voice you can never leave money on the
table just go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner or go to e-voice.com billboard
bill burr damn it e-voice also cuts your
expenses by acting as your business
phone system and your receptionist the
technology could save your business
hundreds of thousands of dollars evoice
starts at only 10 bucks per month
and for that plus you can get a
toll-free ah [ __ ]
plus you can get free 30-day trial right
now when you go to the podcast page at
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner or evoice dot com billboard
billboard that's my website
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner or
to evoice dot com slash bill burr
he got to be kidding me i was like
three-quarters of the way i'm like oh my
god i'm gonna have a perfect game
and then i messed up once i'm like well
i'm still gonna beat three then i had
two and then i'm like don't blow it
god damn it so that was three again
let's do one more here let's see if i
can only make two screw-ups i'll have to
go a little slower
put a little more twinkle in my eye
hulu plus everyone
you've probably tried hulu.com now with
hula plus you can watch your favorite
shows anytime anywhere
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit tv shows and a selection of
acclaimed movies on your television or
on the go with your smartphone or tablet
and it all streams in hd for the best
viewing experience with hulu plus you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like saturday night live community and
family guy you can also check out
exclusive content including hulu
originals like the awesomes starring snl
seth myers and moon boy starring chris
o'dowd from bridesmaids hulu plus also
offers a great selection of acclaimed
films for only 7.99 a month you can
stream as many tv shows and movies as
you want wherever you want right now you
can try hulu plus free for two weeks
when you go to huluplus.com
bill that's a special offer for my
listeners only make sure you use
huluplus.com bill so you can get an
extended free trial and they know we
sent you go to huluplus.com
bill now or click the hulu plus banner
on the podcast page at billboard.com
all right i think that was only two
mess-ups
possibly three
all right anyways let's get back to the
uh let's get back to the old uh
the old podcaster rooney there
um
so
as i mentioned oh this week
they had the uh new york comedy festival
which was why i was at the uh
i was in new york city working at the
beacon theater
um
it was over this this was my weekend i
worked our constitution hall where eddie
murphy taped delirious
and chris rock did i think never scared
or shoot the messenger i forget which
one
um so i got to work that place
and then i did the beacon
you know which is the beacon and then i
got to do the tower theater in philly
so um
it was insane
it was absolutely insane as if my week
couldn't have gotten any better
uh because it was the new york um
comedy festival
there was all these big name comics um
that were in town
and uh bill cosby
was working at the theater down in
madison square garden
and uh
it was on my bucket list
you know i gotta see this guy i saw
carlin i never saw prior
i have to see bill cosby
um i saw don rickles earlier this year
and uh you know there's a lot of people
that i should have seen throughout my
career and i never did because i was too
busy trying to get better myself and i
was always like i'm going to see him i'm
going to see him i'm going to see him
and like i never saw carlin when i was
actually a stand-up comic where i could
have appreciated him even more
i saw him and
i told you this story before i'll tell
it again real quick being a buddy of
mine some at the cape cod melody tent
and
we actually went down there to laugh at
him if you can believe it because my
buddy had convinced me that he was still
doing his more stuff bit
that he hadn't changed up his stuff so
we were driving to the
venue
drinking and laughing going more stuff
like we just would like we're gonna go
down there we actually used to go out
like i went and i saw a live taping of
the morton downey junior show we would
go out to go see stuff like that to
enjoy it and also laugh at the people
that that thought it was great stuff
martin downey judy was great but come on
it was a [ __ ] show right
uh we saw dice
um we love dice we saw him at the
worcester central we didn't go down
there to laugh at him by any stretch of
the means we went down there to [ __ ]
laugh our balls off and we did
um saw him at the worcester center
and but we went to go see carl and went
down there to laugh and i think he was
going to do all his old material
and of course we go there and he had a
brand new killer hour and he was 10
times the comic that he was
the last special just how he just kept
growing throughout his whole career so
anyways but i never saw him
when i was an actual stand-up comic
i saw him when i wasn't a comic so all i
knew was this guy was funny as hell
um so anyways
long story short i
was flying to new york and they had an
article in the new york post that said
that uh cosby was in town and he was
doing the festival so i called up and i
asked if there was any way i could stand
in the back and blah blah blah blah just
check them out
and they hooked me up
and they actually got me to the side of
the stage and i was thinking oh maybe
maybe he'll just walk by and i'll get to
shake his hand no i don't want to bug
him i don't want to bug him so i go
backstage and of course there's like 40
people standing there because you want
to go
you got to see bill
cosby so i'm standing there and then
this woman goes
hey you want to go up and meet him
and i was like meet who and she was and
i'm like cosby and
she was like yeah
so she starts walking up towards his
dressing room and i'm
it's like i had [ __ ] mud and i'm
walking in mud like i was afraid i was
afraid
so i'm walking i'm going are you sure
it's okay are you sure it's okay because
this wasn't somebody running the
festival this was just like a pa that
was bringing me up there
and
it's right before he's going on
and i'm thinking like i
it just didn't seem like this was going
to happen so she walks up knocks on his
door
i hear somebody say come in that's not
him and they open the door and there he
is sitting there with one other guy
and so i walk in
thinking i'm going to get an intro from
the pa and she just closes the door
behind me
so now i'm standing there it's me
this other dude and bill cosby
the other two are sitting down and i'm
standing up
and cosby looks up at me
and he just goes
who are you
and immediately my heart is pounding i'm
like uh
i'm bill burr i'm i'm a stand-up
comedian and he and he interrupts he
just goes and why
are you
here it's not going like oh my god this
is the [ __ ] nightmare i didn't want
to come up here i didn't want to bug him
i was tongue-tied
i had i
there was nothing i i what am i gonna
why why am i here i don't know why i'm
here
i didn't ask to come up here she just
[ __ ] dragged me so it's three
excruciating seconds
after he said and why are you here and
i'm just sitting there with my jaw on
the ground and then he finally lets me
off the hook and he goes you are here
because i asked you to be
and then he motions to a chair and goes
sit down
so i sit down he had no idea who i was
i think he knew that i was a comedian
but i i sat down
and immediately i just had this [ __ ]
ear-to-ear grin on my face that i
couldn't wipe away and i just as i was
sitting down i was like i gotta tell you
this is like meeting the pope
and he goes yes but way more
entertaining i can't do it the way he
did he just had me laughing
and he proceeded
to just start talking to me about how
excited he was about his new special
and about the way
that he
shot the thing and and
and uh the artistic way he's like you
have to see this thing and he was saying
there's no crowd shots
he goes i don't want
the camera on my crowd he goes leave my
people alone
let them laugh if they think it's funny
he goes i don't want the camera on them
and then they get self-conscious and
they feel like they have to and he
imitates their laugh and he does that
cosby ah did that thing it was insane
so then he goes he goes i'm going to
tell you something about shooting a
special and he looks at the other guy he
goes i don't think i should tell him
this
you know what i'm going to tell it i'm
going to i'm gonna tell it to him and he
turns to talk to me and right then the
door opens
and the pa comes back and goes mr cosby
are you ready and he goes oh yes of
course and he stands up and he walks out
[Laughter]
so i never got to hear
that that
the secret of shooting is special
from a guy who i i think you know i i
i've said this before i feel like
richard pryor live in concert and bill
cosby himself run the entire gamut
of
it's like two perfect games
um
i can't i can't explain it and it's just
one just absolutely
like cosby's just totally clean although
he says [ __ ] one time but it's
totally necessary
it's just not
an ounce of fat
in that special just wire to wire is
just sitting down killing not cursing
just
like
i just you couldn't do it any better
as far as just a written special
all the way to prior live in concert
which is just like
i don't that's just
i don't know how to describe that style
just open free going off
not like you don't have your bits but
like
those nights when you're just on as a
comic and you're just tagging every joke
in a three-minute joke becomes a
five-minute joke and a five-minute joke
becomes a 12-minute joke
and then the next time you do your
you're set
you're thinking about how you did it the
last time so you're in your head and
then your three-minute joke that became
a five-minute joke now becomes a
one-minute joke and you burn through an
hour material in 17 minutes and you're
on stage going what the [ __ ] happened
um anyways those are the two perfect
things so anyways then he goes
downstairs
and he walks out on stage and just sits
down
he has like uh
you can't even see it it's like this
clear
mic that um almost like he would be like
typing into on on a keyboard
so it's hands-free kind of thing and he
sits down almost like a catcher
and he's just like like he's sitting
down on a stoop
and just does like an hour uh you know
he was only doing like there was a
number of comics that were on it
um
but he just sits down and
like he did 30 years ago when i saw him
or whatever the hell it was
yeah it was 30 years ago just absolutely
just total command of the crowd
i've never seen anything like it but
there were so many people backstage
talking and that type of thing
that uh i still have to go see that guy
live because i hear
they said when he did his special
he did two shows both 90 minutes
both
all different material
and i brought that up to him when i was
talking to him real quickly i still
can't believe i'm saying this yeah when
i was talking
to bill cosby and he said uh
and he just was humble he goes well you
know i've been doing this for like
50 years
i i should have that much material when
you think it's just like
yeah but it's that's all relevant
you know
don't you have any topical stuff that
you have to throw out it's just
unbelievable so
um
he's touring he's out there he's
part of one of the last ones
from a generation that taught the rest
of us how to do it so if he comes to
your town i i can't recommend it enough
to go out and go see that guy but uh
yeah so that was my week
you know
that doesn't suck does
i don't think so um so what else did i
do let's talk about some of the [ __ ] i
did with the new jersey zone paul versi
you know i'm actually rooting against
the giants not because i hate him but
because paul versey said when they were
owen six that they were going to go on a
run remember i said that you know i got
a feeling you know they they they they
continue you know
so i it's not that i don't want to see
the giants go on a run it's just i don't
want to listen to paul tell me that he
called it
for the next six years
okay
the fact that he's still talking about
cano and all that i don't need another
thing him going ah like when we're both
like when i'm 60 and he's 50. i don't
want to be listening to him talking
about the 2013 regular [ __ ] season
that they could go on a run and blah
blah blah
and also
just having watched the giants you know
win against the patriots in the super
bowl twice when the patriots had him
and they let him off the hook now i'm
not taking away from the giants because
the giants still had to [ __ ] deliver
and jesus christ did they and they all
stepped up and they all made a play
where we didn't
where sante samuels dropped a [ __ ]
interception
you know and we brady to welker six
yards [ __ ] completion that would have
gone for a first down and the game is
over and you leave the door open for him
they are just a blessed team the fact
that you can go 0 and 6
okay and then win your next two games
and only be two games out
in a 16 game season and they have a
horseshoe
buried so far up their [ __ ] ass like
they literally they could actually win
their division
starting oh and six starting oh and six
as a football team
is basically that would be like losing
your first 50 games
as a baseball team going like oh and 50.
okay because what oh and eight is half
the season so owen six i can't i'm not
doing the math i can't even do the map
we'll say that's 40 percent of the
season there's 162 games
that's 40 and we'll just go 40 and 40.
that's well that's like losing your
first 70.
ah gee i don't [ __ ] know it's like
losing a bunch of [ __ ] games and then
somehow not only
do you go on a run you like you win your
division
it's insane
wait did the cowboys win last night i
got to look it up i started watching
that dr j
documentary they were playing the saints
i'm going to guess no
saints at home
let's see cowboys
saints this is entertaining right
listening to some douchebag look up a
score
and i'm going to say the saints one
jesus did they ever 49 17. what the [ __ ]
so now they're five and five
now [ __ ] this i gotta look it up dude
this is [ __ ] hilarious
nfl
let's get me to nfl.com
official website standings here we go
standings what are they a game up now
the giants are three and six
so that that they're two out they're two
back that's [ __ ] hilarious they're
actually tied with the redskins the
washington redskins you ought to be
ashamed of yourselves
you want to be ashamed of yourselves
jesus christ
they went 0-6
the giants went 0-6 and it only took him
nine games to catch you oh wow that's
depressing we're already nine games into
this [ __ ] season
ah [ __ ] it just doesn't it just goes by
too fast it's already november
unbelievable but thank god there's
hockey and i'm actually kind of into the
into the nba this year
um
i don't know but it's it's very hard to
to stay up on both those leagues because
there's so many games and they play like
their seasons just completely overlap
each other have you noticed that there's
baseball football like people are either
baseball football basketball or baseball
football hockey
um
you know if you're going to go if you're
going to try to watch as much as you can
and then you throw in the golf and you
got to watch wimbledon right
i mean no wonder the years are flying by
and your wife has that angry look on her
face
you know which it's just flying oh
another one you guys got to watch watch
the pat summerall documentary
of football life
on pat summerall that's another one
just uh just amazing you know and made
me feel good about my drinking
considering the way they people used to
go back in the day
um
dude that last super bowl i forget the
guy it was before my time
that pat summerall was paired up with
before john madden
um
it was just like an open joke that they
used to go out boozing
like kind of like in a d martin kind of
way
see pat summerall
uh
broadcast team
broadcast partner there we go let's see
if i can find it
oh tom brookshire was that the guy's
name
yeah i think it was tom brookshire and
they actually
before super bowl 13 the second time the
cowboys and the steelers met up
they came on the air and both looked
like [ __ ] and talked about how they'd
been there since tuesday
the game was on sunday or something have
they been there since tuesday and now
they felt like they had been there for
there for nine years and were just
basically openly admitting that they
were [ __ ] hungover and felt like [ __ ]
it was insane so those those are two
documentaries to watch
um oh by the way
i had a great great [ __ ] time when i
was in philly
um whenever i drive to philly down from
new york by the time i get into
philadelphia i absolutely [ __ ] hate
the city
i just hate the fact that you just can't
seem to get off the goddamn jersey
turnpike
you gotta i always take that exit five i
always take the wrong one i gotta weave
my way through like 12 suburban towns
going by a goddamn gazebo to go to a
major city it's a major city you got
four major [ __ ] teams i don't
understand why they don't have some
[ __ ] throughway where i can continue
to drive 70 miles an hour and get to
philly in no time whatsoever i know i'm
taking the wrong one i should take that
one that's the 30 that you go over the
ben franklin bridge but i went over that
that other one exit five we end up going
over like that [ __ ] footbridge
um
then you pissed and you get there and
it's like 12 one ways and going in the
same direction then another one going
the other way and you're like my hotel's
right [ __ ] there how do i get to it
and you're pissed but then you see
mitchell and ness and all the great food
and then you're walking around you have
a great time so anyways
um we went and we did the shows at the
tower theater
crowds were awesome
um just [ __ ] awesome and um
oh and you know was awesome too was some
woman came to my to came to the first
show and as i was walking off stage
like
handed me a loaf of pumpkin bread
because i uh
i mentioned i was talking [ __ ] about how
good my pumpkin bread was so she hands
me this loaf of pumpkin bread as i'm
getting off stage
and i'm laughing like
like because i know why she gave it to
me and i'm walking upstairs and she has
it wrapped very professionally like she
has cellophane around it and then she
has this plastic bag over that with the
twisty a twist tie and now i'm going
upstairs and i walk by the guy i go look
at somebody maybe some pumpkin bread
and you know there's no barcode on it
there's no governmental [ __ ] this stuff
has not gone through any sort of
stuff whatsoever so i'm literally i say
to the the guy backstage i go
do you gotta you gotta have a rat
problem back here can i feed a piece of
this to a rat and just see what happens
to the rat like a little food testing
before i bite into this make sure
there's no weed in it or any [ __ ] like
that
and um
and whatever so i went upstairs and i
was just like i gotta try it
and i hope the person who made it is is
listening it was [ __ ] outstanding
outstanding
uh i'm not gonna say it was better than
mine
that's like saying cosby's better than
prior our pumpkin breads are both
coexisting in that stratosphere and it
would just really be
a a
it would just be a personal personal
preference i i got to tell you um
whoever made that made it and handed to
me it was outstanding version had some
too
and was like it's like i couldn't throw
it out actually paul took it home to his
family so i hope the drugs or whatever
you did to it aren't in the middle of it
because he has kids
[Laughter]
but it was [ __ ] delicious so thank
you very much for that
um
it's very nice of you um and speaking of
battling which is better
my pumpkin bread your pumpkin bread all
right you're in philly
you don't live there or even if you do
live there how do you end a great night
come on
you got to go to geno's or pat's for the
[ __ ] steak and cheeses right
and i'm sure the people in philly oh
[ __ ] both those places your [ __ ] toys
trap you need to go to uncle [ __ ] he's
over here but whatever for an out of
town guy that's what i did
so i go down there and
first he's going so what should we do we
should do pat's or gino's and i'm like
well [ __ ] it why don't we go uh
we'll get one of each then we'll cut
them in half and we'll we'll you know
trade
mix and match do a little surf and turf
and see which one we like better
so of course we go what we go to pat's
first and we order it and it's just one
giant [ __ ] steak and cheese sub and
they don't have even have a plastic
knife fee to cut it up all they have is
a spoon for i don't know what
if you get cheese fries or something um
so fergie's got to tear it in half and i
go over to uh
was standing in line at gino's i'm
eating half of one of uh
pat's right
i got one wit
is what we got and dude it was [ __ ]
delicious
[ __ ] delicious
so then i go to the uh
gino's place
same deal we ordered another one
and as i go up there
i know i had been there before but i
never noticed the sign there
on gino's where it says uh
he's got two signs one says i'm mad as
hell i want my country back
and it's a picture of the uh the
original owner i really don't want to
[ __ ] this up joey vento
there's a picture of him
basically on
with a picture of just the lower 48. i
love how he blows off alaska and hawaii
he wants his country back
and then below that
there's a picture
that says uh
uh this is america
when ordering speak english
and i was just like jesus christ man
that's like some old school
bronx tale
archie bunker [ __ ]
and
i saw it and i was like i was who's
funny to me because there was this table
of like five latino people standing
around
speaking spanish or whatever
eating the food and i'm like wow that is
a testament to how good your [ __ ]
food is where you can just like openly
insult somebody
like that and um well i guess they spoke
english too because they did order i
don't [ __ ] know i'm just saying
that your food is so good that you could
be like consulting that much openly
insulting and uh
people still order it so i looked it up
and there's this whole thing where
this guy joey vento's
son
um um joey vento passed away
and uh his son took over the business
and i guess it was this guy's dying wish
to keep the speak english sign of geno
still up there
i'll read you the article real quickly
here um
it said last week uh
eatery philly ran a photo of rapper
buster rhymes hanging out at geno's
stakes in south philly this was all well
and good but what really caught our
interest was an update to the item
explaining that the speak english sign
is still being proudly displayed at
geno's because it preserves because its
preservation was what
late owner joe event
jesus christ i'm sorry guys because his
preservation was late owner joey vento's
dying wish gino recently
retained neff associates the same public
relations firm that began handling the
joe's
oh yeah the joe's verse chinks racist
cheesesteak drama
oh this is a pr firm
neff pr director kyle flett explains the
geno sign situation in an email today
um he says as you know geno's is under
new management since the passing of joey
vento
vento joey's openly gay son is the new
owner and operator and i think it's
important to inform you that he does not
share all of the polarizing views his
father was famous for i think it's also
important for you to know that we
have retained
uh joe's stakes
blah blah blah blah
whatever i guess it was this guy's dying
wish his dad's dying wish was to keep it
up there so his son sort of caught in
the middle
um i don't know it's actually an intro
almost like an interesting piece of
history
where they have like colored bathroom
only we just kind of see
how far we've come yet haven't come that
far i don't know it was it was pretty
takes a lot to kind of
shock me i was just like
jesus christ and then i felt like well
[ __ ] this place i don't want to eat here
i'll just eat at the other place
and um i just heard well that's owned by
the same family
i don't know for the record i like pat's
better on that night so i it might be
one of those nights where any given
night but they're both absolutely
delicious so then i had to look up this
the joe's verse chinks racist
cheesesteak drama
so uh
i look up this one
by the way all of this [ __ ] is making me
feel much better about being from the
boston area because we seem to get
like
other than the south like when you talk
about racist cities in the north people
always talk about boston
and
i guess there was a place that's now
called like joe's stakes and whatever
um
oh jesus where the [ __ ] is the thing
where's the article here
okay philly is renaming a cheesesteak
shop
that used to be called chinks
um all right
philadelphia capital city of the united
states is a is great at many things it's
great at being within a relatively short
driving
uh unfortunately two topics it is yet to
master are race relations and nuance
um which is why its residents are
freaking out that a philly cheesesteak
shop known since 1949 as [ __ ] steaks
has just changed its name to joe's
steaks and soda shop
uh chinks was names for its original
owner
whose name wasn't [ __ ]
but who boy did he look like one
according to his grade school classmates
um the philadelphia inquirer notes that
the late samuel [ __ ] sherman so some
guy named sam sherman had almond-shaped
eyes so everybody called him [ __ ]
uh folks in the shop's neighborhood
understand why someone somewhere at some
point maybe could be could find the
well-known racial slur inappropriate
but they stopped just short of admitting
that it actually is
and because nothing flavors meat like a
couple of decades of
racism
they
they're pissed that chinks no longer
exist
um
here's our sampling of some of the best
lines of complaints
uh back then ethnic slurs slipped off
the tongue as smoothly as melted
american cheese
cracker barrel hasn't had to change
their name i mean
that could be made into a racist thing
um
others said the passing of chinks
symbolized the neighborhood's decline
uh if the shop had been named with the
slur against blacks that would be
offensive said
terrell jenkins a 44 year old
african-american man but chinks
[ __ ] was a nickname
it could have been a term of endearment
[Laughter]
see that's the one thing that i've
learned about travel it's just people
just give a [ __ ] about themselves so
there's an african-american guy you
think he'd have empathy he doesn't give
a [ __ ] it's not coming in his direction
he's like dad you know it could have
been a tournament dearman sounds like a
white dude at that point you know what
that reminds me of that reminds me of uh
back in the day
one of those
you know england they have that stupid
royalty and these kings and queens and
dutches and dukes and they just all this
pomp and circumstance i guess they don't
make any decisions over there but god
knows i haven't really read up on it so
what the [ __ ] do i know but anyways they
had some sort of polo club over there
and there was some middle eastern guy
who was a member and i think he was one
of the only middle eastern guys
everybody else was these
you know blue blood guys that all you
know that incestuous [ __ ] so they all
have weird ears and [ __ ] up looking
faces like prince charles you know
and um
their nickname for him was [ __ ]
they called him [ __ ]
so that got out and the pakistanian guy
whatever the hell his name whatever
ethnicity he was he said like oh no it
was a term of endearment i don't mind
i just love like that's such like
a
blue blood
roth child level like
[ __ ]
you know
like the soot from your chimney from the
giant fireplace
in your [ __ ] manner
you know no one thinks about soot
anymore first of all most houses don't
even have fireplaces anymore you can't
even use them unless you buy an old one
that's grandfathered in you know them
they have these old [ __ ]
whatever whatever the next style house
up from a manor is you know that one
that they shoot it from the air
and it looks like a public library
except the grounds are so [ __ ]
gorgeous
all the hedgerows
to quote led zeppelin
if there's something in your hedgerow um
so anyway so i was just fascinating for
me to read this
like
i don't know it just just reminded me
this was like 1950s level
sort of racism like uh
like they're reading just [ __ ] and kind
of being in that environment i was
surprised that there weren't some people
with their hair greased back standing
around a like burning trash can singing
doo-wop
had a very bronx tail
sort of vibe to it so um but having said
that those racist sons of [ __ ] make
some great food
they really do and uh i've only ate
there one time so i'm not going to pass
judgment other than to say my experience
that night
pats
pat's got the leg up
all right but that's a divisional
rivalry so they play each other twice in
one season so i got to go back and have
another game down there it was [ __ ]
delicious and i don't regret a second of
putting that poison into my body the
[ __ ] bread was delicious
the cheese whiz all of that toxic
horrific [ __ ] that my body is probably
still trying to process and decide where
it should put it in my body
um
i'm telling you right now i would do it
again tonight and i just had it two
nights ago it was [ __ ]
delicious so thumbs up on the cuisine
thumbs down on the ignorant thought
but uh leaving the sign up
i definitely think the name of the place
if it's racist it should you should get
rid of it but there was something about
leaving the sign up
that um
i don't know to me i looked it more it
as like a museum
like this was the guy
and he was beloved in the neighborhood
yet he thought this way he had another
he had another sign that they actually
took down it said real americans don't
press number two
which was a reference to you know if
you'd like english press one
a primo numero dos you know there's
always this the [ __ ] uh
prima whatever the [ __ ] they say uh
is the spanish
that one to me was actually funny
i don't condone it or whatever but it
was at least it was least clever sort of
racism i just love that whole philosophy
you know give me
i want my country back and that's the
same [ __ ] guy that if a native
american came up
you know and said i want my country back
like you know this guy would immediately
go into some sort of i would imagine i
don't put words in his mouth but i
imagine he would go on some sort of
[ __ ] rant
about how
native americans were savages
you know
as we systematically [ __ ] wiped them
out like a bunch of [ __ ] savages so
whatever it was really interesting it
was delicious food okay let's let's get
to some uh
let's get to some uh some more
advertising then i got to get to the
questions over there
all right here we go let's see if i can
improve
on two screw-ups
legal zoom everybody there are two
reasons not one but two reasons why now
is the perfect time to start your own
business reason number one the economy
is picking up and the longer you wait
the longer you delay your potential
success reason number two
right now you can you can incorporate
your business or form an llc at
legalzoom.com for just 99
legalzooms online process
guides you step by step and you get
total customer support it could be much
easier legalzoom present provides
self-help services at your specific
direction and can connect you to an
attorney but they are not a law firm so
you have a pile of money no so you save
a pile of money that's four strokes
against me get an extra discount and you
enter when you enter burr in the
referral box at checkout i went into the
water
don't wait on the sidelines while others
are taking charge of their futures now
is the best time to get in the game and
launch your business don't put this off
for incorporation trademarks patents and
more just go to legalzoom.com right now
discount code bird burr
that's legalzoom.com discount code burr
good lord that was like the shark when
he blew the masters that was terrible if
legalzoom doesn't pay me this week i
understand
all right let's see if i can go nick
faldo on this one
stamps.com everyone
postage meter companies
used to have the monopoly on printing
postage they could charge you an arm and
a leg to print postage from your own
office but those days are over
now you can use stamps.com instead with
stamps.com get all the benefits of a
postage meter but at a fraction of the
cost all you need is your computer
printer and stamps.com to get official
us postage for any letter or package any
class of mail plus you'll never have to
step inside a crowded post office again
everything you would want to do at the
post office you can do right at home
from your own desk it's so convenient i
use stamps.com to send out my posters my
dvds my t-shirts whatever i'm whoring
myself up with
selling that week and if i can figure
out how to do it someone is dumb as me
you can too right now use my last name
burr b-u-r-r for this special offer no
risk trial plus 110 bonus offer it
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage don't wait
go to stamps.com before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bur bur
that stamps dot com enter bur
all right that was only one screw
up his last chance
to try to win a major
or they'll always say he could never win
the big one
vista print everyone
a business card says a lot about you and
your business are you a hard-working
landscaper a hip and funky salon owner a
loyal dog walker no matter who you are
or what kind of business you have
vistaprint.com has thousands of designed
to say just what you want and today we
just got word of a great offer on their
best business cards get 250 of their
premium cards for only 10 bucks the
shipping is on them too
i created my cards the other day and i
have to say i was impressed at how easy
it was first you choose the design you
want pick your industry there are over
20 or you select a style instead like
bold conservative modern or retro
whatever you want they got it they even
have a personal
um and family section if you're looking
to create a contact on a mommy card
vista print has so many designs to
choose from that you're bound to find
one that says exactly what you want just
the way you want i even stumbled across
the henna tattoo card these guys really
think of everything
once you find a card you like the design
process itself is super easy and fun add
text photos or logos you can even change
colors fonts and move things around you
can be an artist
so again that's 250 high quality premium
cards with shipping included just go to
www.vistaprint.com
click on the hurt us on tv slash radio
button in the upper right hand corner
and put in the promotional code bur
b-u-r-r as you check out make sure you
take a look
at the other marketing products they
offer like postcards flyers brochures
and websites they even can match they
even match your business cards
oh they can even match your business
card excuse me get 250 premium business
cards for dollars including shipping
just go to www.vistaprint.com
click on the hurt us on tv slash radio
button in the upper right hand corner
and put in the promotional code burr
b-u-r-r
wow that was brutal i just really went
off the rails
um okay let's close that forever don't
need to see that okay on to the
questions
answer the question
um
all right oh by the way for all you
alabama fans congratulations you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that really devastated me
oh we had you i i really think if we
scored that first touchdown it would
have been a different thing
you got to protect the [ __ ] ball
you know and then all of us then they
just get the discipline just went out
the window and then completely went off
the rails
you know
and i just have to say nick saban just
completely outclassed
the way his players played and all that
it's absolutely devastating you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right there you happy
okay should i say yes bill i am a 16
year old virgin guy from texas and
really want to go balls deep in a snatch
before college
jesus christ rub one out before you text
me next time
or email me um homecoming is in a week
and this girl who i talked to a lot last
year doesn't have a date because her
date didn't want to pay the 150 bucks
all right you got yourself a wounded
bird things are looking good so far
uh when this year started we had we
haven't talked and i've never texted her
i don't know where she texted me i
didn't even have her number immediately
i knew it was going to be about
homecoming because it was all about
people we were talking about uh that we
oh [ __ ] because it was all people we
were
talking about that week she asked me to
go with she asked me to go with her but
in a way that made me think she was
using me so that she doesn't go alone
yeah there is a bit of that
she's definitely desperate
you know you're kind of like the third
string quarterback
and they both went down so they're
sticking you in there
so i know what you're saying is she
gonna let me throw the deep ball or am i
just gonna have to go in there and take
a [ __ ] knee
right or hand it off
go in the eye formation or the wishbone
anyways he said there's a pretty good
chance i would get laid if i went i told
her i think i that i would think about
it then she offered to pay
for the mum and the food
what is the mom
does she really want to go with me
should i say yes and the host hopes that
i get to slam her [ __ ]
you know dude i really can't figure you
out it's like you're acting like a
virgin by not saying yes to this layup
and then you're just really talking
about
her in a really disrespectful way this
girl is an angel
all right the fact that she's gonna give
it up to a [ __ ]
16 year old virgin show a little bit of
respect but you might be also this might
be your insecurity that you are a virgin
so you're trying to talk really
aggressively about something that you
might have a little bit of fear about i
have no idea look this is what you
should do if you're going to go with
this girl be a [ __ ] sweetheart all
right make her laugh [ __ ] dance
around the dance floor have a great
goddamn time and if the opportunity
presents itself have at it
all right but that's how you go into it
i mean she's already paying for it what
kind of a [ __ ] man i mean i guess
you're a pimp at this point
um a pimp virgin you don't see that very
often
whatever you're doing it seems to be
working but i just have a little more
respect for it that's all i'm saying all
right go in there have a good time
all right
what's that what is that what's that
john madden speech that joe bartnick
always quotes tonight today will be the
greatest day of your life but only if
you win
so good luck man i hope you i hope you
win
all right there you go but be respectful
god damn it all right car purchase
process
hey there bill mcredbeard in balls
big red beard and balls i like that it's
kind of like a law firm
um love the podcast and love the stand
up have tickets to see you in dc tonight
well i hope you enjoyed the show i had a
i had a phenomenal time um he said my
question is about your car purchase
process
when you bought your prius did you do it
in did you do it celebrity style
and send one of your cronies with a
scrooge mcduck style money bag over
oh to the dealership then have it
delivered to your place or did you go in
old school and negotiate face-to-face
were you one of those [ __ ] who
bicker over a hundred dollars or did you
just buy the whole shebang and make some
poor sap sales guys day i asked because
i've been selling cars for 10 years i
find that the people who dicker over the
smallest amount of money are usually the
most miserable [ __ ] during and after
the sale while the people who pay the
most are the happiest customers
i'm happiest customers i have and send
me all their friends and family
uh fellow ginger and sleazy car salesman
um
all right so you own up to it that
you're robbing those people
i tried to uh
i tried to haggle over the price
and uh i was buying the prius
when gas prices were like four four
something a gallon back in like two
thousand
uh seven
so they couldn't keep those things on
the lot so i was just like this is my
offer take it or leave it and they're
like well we're gonna leave it and i'm
like i'm walking out
i'm out of here and they're like all
right see ya
and i needed a car and i was renting one
that was a thing if i had another car if
i actually had a car that i could drive
away with instead of a rental that was
costing me money so i just said all
right [ __ ] it um i'll just pay i'll just
pay it and i'll go do some more stand-up
gigs
um
but just personally speaking if you
can't knock any money off of the car
just because you know that they are
[ __ ] you over
um
you know
one of my buddies does it the best and
he is also a salesman and he looks down
on car salesman he looks at you guys
like like hack comedians as far as like
being salesman he thinks you're the
lowest of the low now listen that's not
my thought that's just his
he just calls them up
and says the car that he wants
and the price that he's going to pay
and he says i'm calling four other
dealerships uh you have till noon to get
back to me he does it something like
that and they get back to him and he
gets it
for the price that he wants
because it's a guaranteed sale he's like
i'm buying a car today and
these dealerships they can't resist that
so i oversimplified it because i don't
i'm not
totally um
you know informed on
i always forget how it goes down so i
can't intelligently
present what the [ __ ] it is that he does
but that's the way he does it um but
anyways i'm actually
you know thinking about um
buying nia a nice car so if any car
salesmen out there
could give me some tips
and present the ins and outs about how
much they do mark because you know i've
heard all that stuff like the sales slip
on the side of the car the car the price
up at the top
is what the dealership pays and that the
dealership doesn't pay for any of the
options and that type of thing which
doesn't seem right to me i feel like
they must get a discount on the options
what is the discount and i also know
that they need to make money
so
what's a good
let's just say if i'm going to go buy a
30 000 car
all right
and if i look at the sheet it's it came
in at 22
or 24 just say 24 and it's got six grand
worth of [ __ ] options or something
like that i don't know if those numbers
make sense
if you're a car salesman like
where should i be should i be in the
middle of that should i be at 24.
um
where should i be let me know and i'll
read it on to other people all right
so i guess and to answer your question
um i was the guy who just kind of paid
i'm not a miserable [ __ ] as much as i
sound like it i'm actually a really uh
i'm a pretty happy guy but you know
talking about how happy you are on
[ __ ] stage i mean it's not really
going to be funny so if i talk about my
frustrations and my fears and my
shortcomings you know
yeah that's where the comedy is all
right there you go all right that was a
twofer all right human farming
billy beerballs
um have you heard of the concept of
human farming it really makes a lot of
sense instead of primitive forms of
slavery the population works and prove
and produces for the elite class the
quality of life is terrible because the
ends to the means of working is really
just to service a higher system you have
no idea you're a part of this video
summarizes it really well uh sleep well
so i actually went to go look at this
thing this human farming and i
understand what they're saying
but they as always you know
they don't seem to i didn't watch the
whole video but it's like in the 13
minutes are they really going to give me
a solution
um
and then also
first of all the guy
narrating it
might be the most arrogant [ __ ] i've
ever heard in my life
i can't even i'll click on it right now
if you want
you know he's just like you know a lot
of people might be confused
hang on hang on hang on ah jesus christ
i gotta get through the dodge durango
commercial here
14 seconds you know he's basically going
like
you know some people get get confused
and look at the government as it's this
thing that's helping them out
blah blah blah blah are you beginning to
understand the cage that you were put in
listen to this guy
and how you can finally
be free
wait wait a minute wait wait wait wait
wait wait let me let me let me let me
get back to the beginning here
this is the story of your enslavement
how it came to be
and how you can finally
be free
like all animals human beings want to
dominate and exploit the resources
around them
all right so that's the tone this guy
takes let's get a little bit further
into this thing here we go occupation
throughout history
and it is now reaching its destructive
climax
human society cannot be rationally
understood until it is seen for what it
is
a series of farms
where human farmers own human livestock
some people get confused
oh [ __ ] i pulled it away there
some people get confused here we go look
at this [ __ ] listen to this talking down
to you
some people get confused because
governments provide health care and
water and education and roads
and thus imagine that there is some
benevolence at work
nothing could be further from
the reality all right so then he breaks
it down and then in the end he goes are
you beginning to understand
the cage that you were in
and he keeps going some people get
confused it's like dude i'm not [ __ ]
confused
all right you arrogant [ __ ] you sound
like you're up your own ass you sound
like you're sitting on top of the
[ __ ] pyramid
all right you know what this this type
of [ __ ] does that it doesn't take into
consideration it doesn't take into
consideration mouth-breathing [ __ ]
morons
that whole philosophy that why does this
guy have this much and this guy has this
much that it's always the rich guy
is
evil and manipulative and undeserving
now i know this is shocking to hear from
me the way i go off on bankers but i'm
really going off on the system of
banking when i'm doing that but like
you know don't you guys have some
[ __ ] friends
that you know they go to work but they
they have no direction they have no plan
and they just sit around [ __ ] moaning
complaining about their [ __ ] life
you know
and they feel like they did they have
like this sense of entitlement that they
just [ __ ] deserve [ __ ]
because well why should this guy be rich
and i shouldn't it's because wait maybe
because he's smarter than you maybe he
busted his [ __ ] ass
maybe you sit around smoking [ __ ]
weed or boozing it up all day like
there's no personal responsibility
that's what i don't like about this
thing there's no like
you know
it's just a hundred percent these people
who are running [ __ ] are 100 [ __ ]
evil and that all these people who are
enslaved are all good people now i'm not
saying that you know
there aren't absolutely brilliant
[ __ ] people but because of their lot
in life they ended up in a sweatshop in
el salvador i'm not saying that but what
i'm saying is everybody in that
sweatshop
you know
is not a [ __ ]
i don't know what it's not it's you know
there's some mouth-breathing morons in
there this is a bad example because i'm
not condoning sweatshop labor either but
i'm just saying go to a [ __ ] sporting
event like i did and just beat stone
sober and just sit around and look at
the [ __ ] people
okay
look at this [ __ ] they're eating look at
this [ __ ] they're drinking look at their
behavior look how their clothes are
hanging off their fat [ __ ] asses
and i know
the food supply is poisoned and i know
that there's a bunch of [ __ ] lies and
all that type of [ __ ] but is there any
effort on the part of that individual
to try to squeegee in front of their
[ __ ] eyes or do they just accept it
and if you do just accept it
you know then
how do i feel bad for you
okay
now i haven't said that
you know racism
all that stuff about you know you're a
third world country i don't condone any
of that [ __ ]
i don't condone sweatshop labor i don't
condone i it'll you should pay [ __ ]
people and they should
you know they should they should be able
to live comfortably
all right
obviously i think that i don't condone
that geno's steak [ __ ] hey this is
america's big [ __ ] english i don't
condone any of that type of [ __ ] but i
don't
i don't also go to that so liberal where
it's just like oh look at that drug
dealer
if he had
the same opportunities i had why he
would be a doctor or a lawyer it's like
why wouldn't he work at enron
or be a piece of [ __ ] banker why would
he continue his scumbagery
why when he becomes in my situation does
he then become an angel i grew up in a
suburb
there was cul-de-sacs in my neighborhood
i sucked at meth
i didn't become a doctor or a lawyer i
tried to i was too [ __ ] stupid
so i don't go into that pie in the sky
and i just can't get past this guy's
[ __ ]
pregnant pauses
some people are confused it's like dude
maybe you're [ __ ] confused do you
have a better idea do you have a better
[ __ ] system i'm sure you do and you
let me guess in your fantasy that you
don't have to [ __ ] put to a test
so it's never so it can't be criticized
because it's not been implemented let me
guess it all works out we're all [ __ ]
arm in arm and racism goes away and
everybody has a nice pair of [ __ ]
loafers as they walk out to get their
newspaper
that was delivered by a paperboy who now
makes 80 grand a year right
i don't [ __ ] know whatever watch it
now that you're you're polluted with my
[ __ ] thought on it
some people are canoes confused some
people look at the government and think
that there's some sort of benevolence
going on just the fact that he uses
benevolence you know
making me feel stupid
what does benevolent mean is that some
sort of [ __ ] uh
i'm doing something for you know what i
should look it up let's look it up b e
and b nevo
oh jeez it just disappeared after the v
it gave up on me like well i can't be
trying to see it he can't be trying to
uh spell that word
um
okay
benevolence let's go with the the the
webster's dictionary
a disposition to do good an act of
kindness a generous gift a compulsory
levy
by certain english kings with no
authority
than the claim
of prerogative well jesus it takes a
left turn on definition number three
doesn't it
all right so i think he's using it in
the first or second
i disposition to do good
um i don't [ __ ] who the [ __ ] knows
all right
anyways let's move on here before we try
and solve the world's problems you can
go ahead and watch it if you want
all right naked picture situation
a sports billistrated i like that one it
wasn't really insulting um oh by the way
the celtics were 0-4 before they won
their first game so i immediately
started looking at the draft for next
year
and which i haven't done in the nba
i think ever being a hockey guy
and i have to tell you i was absolutely
[ __ ] shocked
to see that the top 10 draft picks
projected next year eight of them are
freshmen eight out of ten are freshmen
and the other two
are sophomores like
it's such a tragedy that these guys can
come out early
it just i'm being selfish as a sports
fan because i know that they have you
know a lot of people like it's a money
situation they got to come out they come
from a poor family or just a logical
thing where i'm gonna risk blowing out
my knee playing ball for free or i can
go to the nba now and get a million
dollars i know it's a no-brainer but you
know just back in the day
he got to watch four years
you know of a patrick ewing or a ralph
sampson akeem elijah one you saw those
big men like their their
college careers overlapping each other
and the next great ones and you're
thinking oh wow maybe you can win a
championship by the time
he's a senior or something like that and
just to see like the fact that the
junior and senior classes have just been
so raided
by the nba draft that there's not a
junior or a senior
even projected in the top ten and you're
basically going to draft a [ __ ]
teenager to try to turn the boston
celtics around by the way i'm ordering
the nba package i'm like this is when i
step up as a fan not when they're good
not when they buy a title but when they
suck a bag of [ __ ] dicks that's when
i i'm gonna sit there and watch him rise
up from the ashes
okay naked picture situation hey bill
bill uh hey sports illustrated i'm in
need of some advice sir
um i have a naked picture situation on
my hands although it may not necessarily
be what you're thinking well it's either
you or
your girlfriend
i would guess uh he goes so there's this
girl
this lady that went to the same graduate
school as me and this girl was a real
[ __ ]
dude don't do this if you have a naked
picture of her don't do it he goes we're
talking pure evil
she was in school to be a producer and
she managed to alienate and demean every
single person that ever worked with her
she was manipulative and awful to
everyone oh it sounds like she's going
to have a successful career she gets
into corporate america all i'm hearing
here is corner office
she was manipulative and awful to
everyone
even her boyfriend who she emasculated
constantly even in front of his friends
well that's on him
walk out the door what you gonna do give
you a suplex go [ __ ] yourself
i got a hand and a world full of [ __ ] i
don't need you anymore lady
um now before i continue i should
probably say that i realized almost
immediately how evil this girl was so i
always kept my distance and never
associated with her in any way
uh so that this isn't personal
now let's get to the issue at hand okay
so he's painted her as completely evil
and he's painted himself as being this
even keeled rational person i like this
it's almost as though he wrote the email
um now let's get to the issue at hand i
happen to be
perusing the internet one day in the
manner that all men do
oh aren't you an eloquent little [ __ ]
huh
you mean looking at [ __ ] porn
look at you dancing around this i'm you
know i'm starting to think that this
woman is innocent and you're actually
evil person as you continue to try to
paint yourself as a [ __ ] hero who's a
member of a polo club
you're rubbing one out yet filthy
[ __ ] animal
i'm not judging you i do it too happily
big grin on my face waving at the
government and as i rub one out
as i as i actually as i bust a nut i say
into the camera that i can't see that's
watching me it's okay i didn't want to
run for office anyways i say that as i
have an auger as i have a uh orgasm
i can't even talk this week
um anyways he said in the manner that
all men do and i happen to come across
some naked selfies that this girl took
on one of those tumblers devoted to uh
that kind of thing if you're curious
now my question is without trying to
sound like an evil scumbag
uh probably too late should i do
anything with them i could probably give
a lot
of closure and satisfaction by sending
them out to the people she's [ __ ] over
in the past wait is is it's this girl
oh that this girl took
okay
um
wow
so she treats people like that
during the day and at night she takes
naked selfies of herself
um
all right
i know this girl
i know this kind of girl
all right okay
here we go let's let's just try to pick
this back up this this girl she's like
uh yeah she's like that [ __ ] wall
street guy that's stealing money and
knight needs to go to a hooker with a
[ __ ] orange ball in his mouth
you need so i i think this girl is oh
man well maybe this is like a
narcissistic thing
is she taking pictures of herself like
she's just this piece of meat or she's
trying to look hot
the human [ __ ] psyche man it's just
it's [ __ ] insane
you know
i don't judge and eat it because i'm out
of my [ __ ] mind too all right
let's let's continue here
on one of those this is a really great
email there's so many [ __ ] levels to
this you guys have i can't tell who's
out of their mind here her or or you're
like
oh you're out of your mind and this girl
actually shot you down because you want
to take her out for a cup of coffee
um
should i do anything with them i could
probably give a lot of closure and
satisfaction by sending them out to the
people she's [ __ ] over in the past to
be clear i would never do this with
someone's pictures that were meant
privately for me but these were already
posted publicly online
by her or someone else should i
anonymously send out a link to people or
just kind of laugh quietly to myself
about the whole thing and keep it under
wraps any advice would be appreciated
well what you're doing as far as like
justifying your your role in this if you
were to do it that they were already up
there is kind of like the drug dealers
saying like well if i didn't sell the
drug someone else would
um
so
i think you shouldn't do anything
and i don't i don't know why
i don't know why like
what am i trying to say here
like what what do you think is funny
about him i mean what is the big deal
somebody wants to put some naked photos
of themselves up there they like
themselves they think they look good i
don't understand why it's considered
like nudity and that type of thing is
considered that way
um
i mean she's doing a porno i can see
then why she can't get a [ __ ]
job at johnson and johnson but you know
she's got some naked photos who gives a
[ __ ]
she's probably the
best shape of her life you know
i mean i personally i wouldn't do it who
the [ __ ] wants to look at me naked jesus
what the [ __ ] that actually disgusted me
[Laughter]
so anyways um you know what do don't do
that man you're just gonna you're
getting drawn into her [ __ ] world
okay that if that woman is the way you
painted her out to be she has a bunch of
issues
and the best
kind of guy she's ever gonna attract is
some ballast [ __ ] spineless jackass
that she's not going to respect
um
if i had a guest she's a woman who needs
a guy to tell her what's what
and [ __ ] uh you know put a hurting on
her
you know
in the bedroom
she needs to be face down in the pillows
being told what the [ __ ] to do
that she's got some sort of [ __ ]
issue man but you know just be happy
you're not gonna work for her she's out
of your life okay and she's you know and
if she walks around treating people like
that she's never going to really
develop
um
lasting relationships meaningful
relationships
she's not going to have people in her
life
that would step out in front of a bus
for
you know
so she's never gonna get the full human
experience i i feel like that is
enough of a punishment
you don't need to go in there and like
that that's really like a uh i know a
vengeance thing is very seventh grade
girl and i think you're above that
just you know
just leave him alone and continue to
jerk off to him you [ __ ] creep
not gonna lie to you i would too i'm not
judging you welcome welcome to my level
all right
french revolution and bankers
uh hi there billy bandwagon i've been a
fan of the monday morning podcast for a
while now and you were on the crap you
were on the crab fee
podcast oh yeah with jay lassen
on the all things comedy network
everybody he said it reminded me of
something pre-revolution france was
almost identical to the way the us is
now
oh god i hate when people keep
predicting the demise of this country
like they're giving us some sort of
insight like people in this country
can't see it coming
all right i'm not saying every mouth
breathing [ __ ] sees it coming but you
know anybody who has
any sort of intelligence we see it
coming okay
all right there mr [ __ ] rubbing your
goddamn chin
um actually he's probably an american
too
all right france in 1787
had grinding poverty tax inequality and
was nearly bankrupt from the seven years
war
ah and then he writes familiar
question mark uh i'm not even gonna read
this [ __ ] thing you're already sew up
your own ass
wow i never looked at it that way wait
does history repeat itself gee you're
really onto something here sir
good [ __ ] lord you know what's funny
about this type of [ __ ] is this probably
isn't even this person's thought they're
probably just regurgitating something
else that they've read from a website
which i do all the [ __ ] time i do the
exact same thing you're doing here sir
except i don't go familiar some people
some people are confused why can't
people just present a [ __ ]
an opinion without like patting
themselves on the back about how [ __ ]
smart they are all the time
you know you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] just
like me okay i'm gonna read this and i'm
gonna i'm gonna skip over
familiar does that ring a bell
pot calling the kettle
uh with your [ __ ] smoking jackets you
[ __ ] all right here we go jesus [ __ ]
christ
all right
he goes familiar it should be the modern
us
actually has worse
wealth and tax inequality than 1787
france
and even pre-fall of rome dude this is
all old [ __ ]
i've already heard this theory a zillion
times before you presented and you know
and i'm not gonna [ __ ] read this
and get all [ __ ] depressed because i
understand this this is why i got out of
conspiracy theory and just got a dog and
i'm sitting here watching the bread and
circus of [ __ ] sports like i never
have before because there's no way out
of this rather than present this [ __ ] to
me i want you to write back to me and
give me your solution you give me the
[ __ ] solution rather than pointing
out the [ __ ] obvious as you rub your
goddamn chin
all right
jesus [ __ ] christ all right sorry i
was having such a great god damn day
geez we're an hour and a half in here
i'm a long-winded uh
son of a [ __ ] this week all right
uplifting documentaries couldn't come
soon enough on the podcast
hey there billy boy love the podcast and
all your specials can't wait to see you
in dublin in a few weeks you're a good
man
tell all those other irish [ __ ] to come
out and see this german irish [ __ ] we'll
all drink some [ __ ] bushmills
afterwards what do you say
and i is
billy red faces bright and gabe
um i got a heartwarming documentary for
you
since blackfish and dirty wars might
have got you down a bit i appreciate
that people i love when you send the
documentaries that are eye-opening
and make me feel like i want to kill
myself but also every once in a while
you got to give me a little sugar
um so he goes they might have got you
down a little bit
here's some uplifting stuff it's called
the pipe and it's about a tiny village
in the in the west coast of ireland
taking on a massive oil corporation and
winning i love it already
even if it isn't true i love it
um it focuses on the community's refusal
to have a dangerous pipeline running
through their village it shows the
vicious brutality of the cops against
the protesters and in particular five
men who go so who go so far as to serve
time in prison to get justice dude those
guys are saints
that's when you are committed
to a cause
all right and that's when you know
they should make a movie about you
and then [ __ ] actors who have
personal trainers and microbiotic diets
you know show up with abs
and get to play you and your life story
that william wallace [ __ ] you know five
men who go so as far so
so far as to serve time in prison to get
justice
that's that's [ __ ] they don't they
don't make they don't make men like that
anymore
well i guess they do they made five of
them on the west coast to ireland
god bless them for once the people win
and as a recent development in the case
has seen the shell oil company have lost
their license for work on the west coast
of ireland i'm watching that today
today here's the link it's up on youtube
everybody you should check that out it's
called the pipe
and another
one for the full documentary
oh i guess okay this is the link for the
trailer is on youtube but if you want to
watch the full thing we'll have these
links
um if for some reason you don't you
can't
if you go to surf for [ __ ] you can't
find it like i always do it's called
www.filmsforaction.org
watch slash
the
underscore pipe
underscore two zero one zero
slash again those are all backslashes by
the way
that is a backslash right yeah backslash
all right all right that's the podcast
for this week everybody
um i wanna thank everybody who came out
to my shows
this weekend in dc new york and
philadelphia it was just it was [ __ ]
i'm going to use the words magical
there i said it at the risk of everybody
you know coming at me in a homophobic
way i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't i like the twinkle toes so come
at me that way i don't give a [ __ ] all
right it was a magical weekend
i had a great time and you know what
it's even going to get more there's
going to be even more fairy dust on my
career this weekend the final leg
of the billy red state tour
all right um i am playing in
uh deadwood south dakota
november 15th november 16th i'm at the
brady theater in tulsa oklahoma and then
i'm wrapping it up at the orpheum
theater in wichita kansas i will be
coming out taking pictures and signing
[ __ ] and all that i apologize to people
who came out this weekend um to the
earlier shows
um
a couple of nights i had early shows and
i can't go out there because it slows
[ __ ] down and then i get in trouble
with the union because they have to go
dark so i can't go out there and load
the other crowd in so i really feel bad
about that because i actually really
enjoy going out and saying hello to
people so my apologies
to uh people on the first show of um
in philly and in new york
um and the second show the beacon i
actually came out there late
because uh i had a lot of friends and
[ __ ] coming up there so i got some guilt
about that but
all right
the deadwood show the oklahoma and
wichita i'm coming out after all those
shows
and whatever you want to do pictures
autographs whatever you want to do i
really appreciate everybody coming out
it's been a hell of a [ __ ] year
and uh there you go and then i got one
more gig
southern connecticut state university in
new haven connecticut on november 23rd
and and after that i got one last giant
tour
and that's when i do the european tour
and i'm gonna [ __ ]
do my best
to [ __ ] murder when i go over there
um i'm really
i'm amped up for these shows man i got
to finish strong and then the last one
the wilton theater
in los angeles my home city here and
it's going to be me in the entire
rose bowl
deus is going to be there
all right the ocean's 11 of the rose
bowl everybody is going to be there it's
going to be me
joe bartnick
jason lawhead and andrew themeless
that's it the four horsemen
of the [ __ ] rose bowl we're all going
to be there all doing stand up at the
will turn theater to bring in the new
year
you know we'll be smoking cigars
drinking one quick thing of scotch
before we go home and go to bed and then
go to see the granddaddy of them all the
next day it's going to be a hell of a
[ __ ] night
that's going to be an unbelievable
[ __ ] night i'm calling it right now
if you ever want to see the [ __ ]
beautiful knuckleheads that i hang out
you can see hang out with you i'm
telling you go to that show all right
i'm done with that
hype of my own [ __ ] here's the final
thing here uh now that the show's over
don't forget to sign up for your free
trial of hulu plus hulu plus lets you
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere on your tv pc smartphone or
tablet support this podcast
and get an extended free trial of hulu
plus when you go to the podcast page at
billbird.com and click on the hulu plus
banner or go to huluplus.com
bill that's huluplus.com bill okay
that's the podcast for this week
have an excellent week good luck god
bless go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll see
you out there on the road